this is Jocko podcast number 352 with me
Jocko willink
I feel certain I am going mad again
I feel we can't go through another
of those terrible times
I shan't recover this time I begin to
hear voices and I can't concentrate
so I am doing what seems the best thing
to do
you have given me the greatest possible
happiness you have been in every way all
that anyone could be
I don't think two people could have been
happier until this terrible disease came
I can't fight any longer
I know that I am spoiling your life that
without me you could work
and you will I know
you see I can't even write this properly
I can't read what I want to say is that
I owe all the happiness of my life to
you
you've been entirely patient with me and
Incredibly good I want to say that
everybody knows it
if anybody could have saved me it would
have been you
everything has gone from me but the
certainty of your goodness
I can't go on spoiling your life any
longer
and that right there is the final work
of the English writer Virginia Woolf it
was a suicide note that she left to her
husband Leonard Virginia Woolf
was born into an affluent family she was
well well cared for as a child she was
homeschooled in English and Victorian
literature from a young age she attended
the ladies department of King's College
in London she was
Successful by any measure
and she wrote a bunch of successful
novels
she authored more than 500 essays and
reviews she had friends and family and a
long seemingly happy marriage
and yet throughout her life with even
with all those opportunities and
advantages and benefits and privilege
that she had she
suffered from mental health issues she
had mood swings and depression and manic
excitement and psychotic episodes
and she attempted suicide twice
before she was successful in killing
herself in 1941. so
how does that happen
what what is going on there and and
psychiatrists today they hypothesized
that she had a mental health problem
in particular likely bipolar disorder
which used to be called manic depression
and we've talked about Mental Health on
this podcast we've talked about mental
health issues facing veterans we've
covered some
tragic
horrible suicides
including Chad Wilkinson
job price
Charles White whittlesley Lewis polar Jr
we've also talked about
non-military suicides we talked about
Iris Chang
Iris Chang who was the author of the
best-selling book New York Times
best-selling book the rape of Nan King
and she had a nervous breakdown in
August of 2004 and was placed on a wide
variety
of prescription medication but over time
the medications only seem to amplify her
issues and she was diagnosed with
reactive psychosis
and put on even more medication
and on November 8 2004 she wrote when
you believe you have a future
you think in terms of generations and
years when you do not
you just live by the day but by the
minute
it's far better that you remember me as
I was in my Heyday as a best-selling
author
each breath is becoming difficult for me
to take the anxiety can be compared to
drowning in an open sea
I know my actions I know that my actions
will transfer some of this pain to
others indeed to those who love me the
most
please forgive me
and the next day November 9th 2004 she
killed herself with a pistol
so these are topics that we've certainly
addressed we've talked about them
initially really with Jordan Peterson
and focus them focus on them in in the
most recent podcast the last podcast we
did 251 with Marcus and Amber Capone
but it's an area
you know it's an area that I still lack
even basic understanding of what mental
health disorders are where they come
from what we can do to prevent them or
overcome them in some way
luckily today we have some experts from
that field
Dr Carlin Pleasants and Megan Harrison
Dr Pleasants is a clinical psychologist
who specializes in adult and Adolescent
psychotherapy
she's also the chief clinical advisor
and a managing partner at a new
treatment center
in Scottsdale Arizona and Megan Harrison
holds a master's degree in marriage and
family therapy with significant
experience working with families
affected by transgenerational trauma and
mental illness
and Megan is the CEO and managing
partner at a new treatment center in
Scottsdale
so
um thank you both for joining us
thanks for having us yes thank you yeah
it's great to meet you um you know I
mentioned that sort of my my
introduction to psychology
I would say was having uh Dr Jordan
Peterson on this podcast and and that's
when I I realized
I just didn't understand at all
what was going on and what what it meant
to have a mental health issue and I
realized when he was on the podcast as
he was talking through some of the
problems that people have
I realized that the Mind well this is my
simple caveman way of translating what
he was saying
was that your mind is like a car
and sometimes the car breaks down or
sometimes there's you know you blow a
gasket or your oil is low and when that
happens you take it into a mechanic
and the mechan the mechanic diagnoses
what the problem is oh you blew a gasket
here's what we need to do to fix it
and so
I realized that in many ways the mind
can do that too you can blow up a gasket
and there's people psychologists or
therapists that can diagnose what the
problem is and have methodologies and
protocols to get those things
fixed
so I I again in my caveman brain
realized that
psychologists and therapists are like
mind mechanics that have seen that's
what that's what triggered it for me
that's what triggered that thought was
he was telling me about oh I'd see this
case this type of case you know he'd see
it again and he'd see it again and he's
again and you develop a protocol on how
to deal with it just like oh your car's
making this noise okay here's what the
problem is and you see that over and
over again you develop a protocol so you
to
welcome and you to our mind mechanics as
far as I can tell
um let's talk about how you guys got
here just a little bit of background
just so we we get familiar with you so
let's start with you Carlin
um where'd you grow up how did you end
up in this scenario that you're in
sitting here right now okay let's see
well I grew up in the Bay Area
California
and one of the things I think is really
funny about my story is I didn't
understand how I got here until much
much later
looking back and trying to figure it out
for a very long time I was
I was one of those folks when people
would say so why did why did you go into
psychology why did you come become a
psychologist I would say things like oh
I just like helping people I'm a good
listener
I'm interested in how the mind works
which are are true things
but really going back and taking a more
in-depth look at my journey
it started when I was a kid you know I
had some pretty serious physical
limitations and physical illnesses that
you know kept me out of school for a
long time I did not take a single PE
class my entire Scholastic career
um didn't get to participate the same
way as other kids did was missed a lot
of things was absent a lot of the time
and I remember being really young and
thinking like is this it like is this it
can can there be some other
way of being some other way of living
because it's you know it was lonely and
and as a kid like that the sense of
feeling different like I don't really
belong how old were you when these
health issues started was this like I
was diagnosed when I was two
too with like really severe respiratory
and lung problems
and back then
I mean we're talking early 70s right
like treatment was not as it is now
people didn't understand I mean my mom
talks about how I was sick as a an
infant and it took two years for a
doctor to say oh I I think I know what
she has talk about a mechanic right
she's taken me lots of lots of mechanics
over the years
um
and you know treatments weren't as
advanced as they are now so growing up
all through Elementary School junior
high high school feeling very separate
and different and not included and
knowing that people you know I thought
it was kind of weird how come you how
come you don't come to all the things
how come you don't take PE how come you
sit and I'll recess when we all go
outside right which on one hand doesn't
sound I mean whatever it's the plight of
a kid
but when I really look back and think
about it it was that sense of feeling
alone and really misunderstood and not
included in things and wondering like
there's got to be more like this can't
be it this just cannot be it for for me
for people so early on
I remember thinking when I grow up like
I want to be a doctor I want to be
somebody who helps basically helps
people like me again and a young brain
thinking well if I feel like this
probably everybody feels like this and I
don't want people to feel like this so
maybe I'll help kids or I'll help people
with
respiratory problems or I'll help people
with medical illnesses
and it just kind of developed that way
this idea of wanting to
I don't know in some way help ease the
suffering
that other people
experience and and make sense of of what
was going on now again I don't remember
it like this at the time in my mind I
just wanted to help people so did you
apply yourself at school were you like I
need to get straight A's so I can be a
doctor I was like yeah so over I mean I
for for what I couldn't do over here I
made up for it way over here so lots of
good grades lots of degrees lots of
academic awards did you go to school
with the intent of becoming a doctor at
what point did you think Psychology was
the the place to go for a while I was
gonna I wanted to go into medical
medical doctor and then when I learned
that you have to take a class called
anatomy and look at bodies but yeah this
might not be for me uh like you were
screaming it's totally squeamish so I'm
like yeah I don't know if that's then
gonna work out for me very well to go
that direction
um but it also again it the the Insight
of this came through hindsight is I was
so curious about
really the mental part of it right the
experience of feeling isolated and
disconnected and
how that left you feeling or me feeling
um like lonely and depressed and kind of
like
wanting more right so I got a little a
little bit more Curious in the like
psychological Department of what happens
for people who have an illness what
happens for people who
feel separate and different from
everybody else who are left out who are
bullied like what what happens
psychologically
so I definitely made a turn along the
way was that was that in college
um I would say maybe High school-ish
going into college
um
just you know kind of a fascination with
um well how the mind works and and and
you know in some ways unlike
um going to a mechanic a lot of the
psychological experiences that a person
might have in reaction or relation to
all of these different events you don't
see them like you know we can go into a
doctor and take take a listen to your
head and go oh I I recognize that
clicking I know exactly what to do there
are these kind of invisible unseen
experiences that make it a little bit
more challenging to to figure out or
understand what exactly is going on
um so that Curiosity I just remember
High School probably going into college
just curious like how does this work
like why do why do I feel this way but
this person I met also had an illness
when she was young and she seems to be
okay like why did I suffer or why was I
okay over here but this guy couldn't
do grades you know do so so this kind of
curiosity about how the mind influences
the experiences and I remember sitting
in a I was probably getting close to
getting my first degree and uh in a
kind of a pathology class kind of a
mental illness class on mental illness
and the pathology of illness the
professor said how many show of hands
how many in here believe that you're in
here to
help people you just want to do good in
the world you know be the good student
me me
um along with most of the other class
and he's like okay how many of you in
here think that you have chosen this
field or chosen this uh part of the
field because you've got your own stuff
you might need to work out
that one's like not not me not me not
not a hand or maybe like half hand
um and by the end of that class it was
the reverse everybody was like yep I've
got my own stuff I need to work out
that's partly why I'm here
all right so that started the um
I think the kind of
budding awareness that this isn't just
about for me it wasn't just about
helping people and being a good listener
but it was about
understanding myself and hopefully
through the process being able to take
that experience and help other people
whether that's
not feel so alone or understand that
there are options available or that this
isn't kind of the fate of your life
um because you have this illness or this
experience
so yeah I definitely have swung the from
here like I'm I'm just really altruistic
all the way over here to no that life is
hard sometimes life is really hard and
when you factor in
like my experience growing up with an
illness also growing up in a family
where there were a lot of issues and not
just in my immediate family but
generational I mean you and I Megan have
talked about this of
trauma and addiction and loss and
wartime like you you kind of inherit a
little bit of that along the way
so my curiosity over time
you know expanded Beyond just my own
experience but how does this happen in
families how does this happen through
generations how do you find we had a a
client we saw at the treatment center
for a long time who had schizophrenia
two siblings a sister who did not have
schizophrenia a Brotherhood dead
parents were really really lovely great
people did not seem to have a lot of
stuff going on but the dad's brother the
dad had three brothers he was one of
four all three of them had schizophrenia
so this idea right of like okay some of
this
is passing down through generations not
just at a
like a genetic level but what you're
exposed to and what you're seeing and
what you're
experiencing and what you're witnessing
um so the again for me the Curiosity and
the the interest was about
how do these things happen how do they
go from here to here to here to here and
what can we do to shift that so people
aren't just
kind of living out this emotional
inheritance or this traumatic
inheritance depending on what was going
on in the family how do you break that
chain how do you do something different
how do you
set your own life up to go in a
different trajectory than maybe how it's
been going and then your kids and their
kids and their kids
yeah it makes sense that uh like if
you're gonna get a like a personal
trainer because you want to get in shape
it would be kind of if you saw that that
personal trainer had gone through some
sort of transition themselves you go
okay this person kind of knows what I've
been through so you kind of got that
Vibe going I can say Five Below I do too
it's okay oh my the you kind of have
that Vibe so what degrees did you end up
with what what'd you end up with you
said you went got like degree upon
degree yeah so I got a Bachelor's degree
in Psychology which unfortunately in our
field nowadays that doesn't mean a whole
lot other than you went to school for a
few years and learned a bunch of things
about the brain
um got my Master's in counseling
also in California and then got my
doctorate in Clinical Psychology down
here in San Diego
all right uh Megan yes let's let's talk
about you where'd you grow up how did
you end up here sure
um feels like a big question I I grew up
in southern Wisconsin really small town
beautiful there
um not much to do in that area you're
probably fishing
my dad owned a chain of grocery stores
and my mom worked uh just cleaning
houses and
um working for my uncle's scrap metal
business whatever we could do and my dad
that I'm speaking to came later on in
life as well with like the chain of
grocery stores so the first part of my
life was just me and mom
um and so she taught me definitely hard
work but there wasn't much to do where I
grew up you were bowling curling fishing
hunting or going to the bar that was
about it
um curling yeah curling just made the
podcast for 352 podcast deep and we just
got into curling it's a big deal in
Wisconsin let me tell you
um it's very cold for about eight months
out of the year so
um
yeah I mean my store I I was born into a
family system that had definitely been
impacted by just generations of trauma
um you know abuse addiction mental
health issues on the very severe end and
um you know I you know similar to what
Carlin is saying I don't know that like
sitting here right now like the only
intentionality in that for me and coming
into this therapy world was just this
idea that through life
um every step I took forward in terms of
overcoming uh just brought me further
into the life that I envisioned for
myself and it and that was sort of my
intention in that way but I knew growing
up in that environment that there was no
way I was going to be able to do
something different for myself or do
something different for the family I
wanted to have if I stayed there and so
from a very young age I sort of started
my path towards independence I started
working at a very young age
the military sort of came into my life
as this idea of like here's an
opportunity to go somewhere to do
something I actually was finishing some
high school stuff at a community college
um and uh was uh watching the September
11th occurrences in 2001 and I just
remember looking at the screen and being
like
oh this is this is this is what I'm
gonna do I had entertained the military
for a period of time and I had thought
maybe this was my opportunity but it was
in that moment that I was like okay like
this I feel a sense of purpose like
drawn to something and in the
environment that I grew up in I kind of
always knew that I wanted something
different for myself but I did I lacked
a lot of Direction and people in my life
to kind of help me guide in that way
education wasn't particularly valued or
seen as like a possibility and at that
point in my life I hadn't had enough
experiences other than just like
surviving in a lot of ways to um
see see that as possible for myself to
see ready to like go to school and do
that route and so the military just felt
like like okay this is this is what I'm
gonna go do and there's like something
really important that's happening I need
to go do it and it was about a year
later August of 2002 that I was on
active duty and and what do you what did
you join um I joined the Navy how'd you
pick that being in Wisconsin you know
it's really interesting I think it was
it had to do with the recruiter at the
time because I was I was definitely a
youth that was you know getting you know
some help from the community and
different things and at that time in the
midwest you know recruiters would come
into those areas and introduce
themselves and such and so I just
remember him as being somebody that
um I was like okay like he feels he
seems confident like I I he always
carries himself like like this is like
something I want to be a part of um and
it sort of seems cliche but at the time
it was everything for me because I
didn't you know the friends that I had
at the time and I had you know been
living with friends at a very young age
and such like weren't really going a lot
of places jail I lost a lot of friends
to you know death you know suicide
overdoses there was just a lot of that
in my life
um and so just being around somebody who
um just sort of represented like a
possibly different future and like life
was was huge for me it was like a role
model Mentor
um and uh so I I joined what job did you
sign up for so I came in as a signalman
and that's what I went to a school for
but I dates myself a little bit because
it was already kind of like a dying rate
at the time so I went to a school to be
a single man and um my first orders were
actually to the USS Kitty Hawk and I in
Japan at the time and I was um
like set to leave about a week later and
my orders got canceled because there
wasn't enough birthing for females at
the time and I was rerouted to ACB one
in San Diego and I got there and um
I was getting issued Camis and boots and
like we were getting ready to deploy to
Kuwait because this was like August of
or this was like latter part of 2002 so
we were like getting ready to go
overseas for everything that was
happening during operation enduring
freedom and during that time and so
um I was like what what did I just get
myself into because I thought I was
going to a ship and then here I am in
like a whole different world is I'm sure
you're familiar the CVS are just a whole
different realm and such and so but it
was um it was such a blessing for me
because it was like a form of
re-parenting like the amount of
structure that I went into I knew
exactly what was expected of me and it
was also the first time that I learned
how much I think because of the
environment I grew up in that I um I
thrive in in crisis in some ways like
things get crazy Uh something's
happening everything for me just kind of
calms down and I I I wanted to lead and
I found myself in a lot of leadership
positions I found myself an opportunity
like volunteer for this volunteer for
that I'll do it and it really gave me
the opportunity to um just build a sense
of self for the first time the community
the feedback that I was getting
um
was just huge for me and then all kinds
of doors opened up for me the idea of
like I could go to school I could do
this
um
my first interest in doing some
counseling such actually came from I
thought originally I was going to go to
school to be
um to do organizational psychology to
for leadership like that was really my
goal I always wanted to be a leader for
me because before you joined the
neighborhood once you got in once I got
in you know I and I I was just kind of
drawn into these situations where I knew
that there was like
um I don't know if you want to call it a
natural leadership quality but there was
just like this part of me that I had
gone through so much and I had overcome
so much that it was like people need
need
that you know to like hear that story to
be a part of that like it just um it was
a really powerful thing for me
um and I was realizing for other people
as well at the time and so
um I got offered an opportunity to do
some work with families in uh pre and
post-deployment
um sort of support and it was very
logistical at the time how do you
support families and like um
you know preparing for the logistics of
bills or separation or what's going on
but what I what I realized at that time
was that
there was a significant amount of
support that these families needed and
understand like how much role shifts
were happening when one of the the
partners would deploy and that I'm
making this new group of friends well my
my husband or my wife is gone and
they're making their new group of
friends and our kids are getting used to
me as playing like both mom and dad and
doing these different roles and they
just did not have the resources to be
able to deal with that and I think
because I had gone through what I did as
a child I I could recognize things
related to like mental health or
relationship issues or things like that
I didn't really have the skill set yet
to know exactly what to do with that
other than just my mindset was always
like you just do keep moving forward and
and one step at a time and you make
healthy decisions and you recognize that
you know I don't exist in a vacuum and
the things that I do matter and how I
treat people matter and I could support
people a lot with that but it was um
that was what first drew me to the idea
of counseling and at the time I was a
working when I decided to go to school
for counseling I was working as a
contractor for hsc3 so this was actually
how long did you end up doing in the
Navy so I did five years so I did four
years on active duty and then I extended
for a year how was that first deployment
to Kuwait it was
um intense
um you know the we were at the Kuwaiti
Naval Base we came in during a time
where really nothing was set up our goal
is that being the CBC aceb1 and acb2
were there at the same time so we got
there we knew we're not leaving for a
while
um
yes they definitely are and definitely
make friends with Builders because your
your Camp will be real nice and you'll
get a nice little shelf up there and all
the things that you need so I'll steal
you whatever
I learned how to be very uh resourceful
there was also some aspects of being in
the military as a female in that type of
environment and do a lot of things that
were going on during that time that that
made it a scary situation sometimes too
you want to feel safe in that
environment but there was um
you know you're you're in the middle of
the desert and people are going through
wartime and we had you know incoming
missiles coming in we're running you
know taconyx bosses that are buried in
the ground for like shelter like people
were um on edge during that time for
sure and so um uh but I learned a lot um
and if anything it was walking away from
that knowing that I could um
you know I could
it doesn't matter what life throws at
you if you just keep moving forward like
you you get through it um for sure so I
could if I can interrupt I remember you
telling a story one time making about
like having to dig dig holes to sleep in
the ground and having like your gun
there because of like how big the
Scorpions were oh and like having to
protect yourself and guard yourself from
the Scorpions while you're in a hole in
the desert at 127 degrees and you're
like 19. yeah
yeah I think you can pretty much handle
whatever is going to come your way in
life
but I mean this is sort of that that
where you're talking about earlier where
one person can have one situation
growing up and another can have an
entirely different situation and and how
you choose to respond is gonna very much
so shape the outcome of who you are and
so for me I just uh you know there was a
lot of opportunity to move into fear and
have fear make you small and for me it
was just like I'm just going to keep
going but there wasn't at that time in
my life I can't say I mean I was very
young that I was intentionally like this
is what I'm doing to overcome or that
really wasn't there for me it just like
uh stopping or or not moving or going
backwards wasn't an option just keep
moving forward with whatever kind of
presented itself to me so um so yeah I
was there for a year and actually didn't
find out until the day before we were
leaving that I was leaving so it was
like you know come up to like here's
your plane ticket you're leaving
tomorrow I'm like cool and at the time
you know cell phones weren't allowed we
weren't we couldn't have any of that and
so there was two phones in the camp for
a camp of um
I don't quote me on this but there was a
lot of people I mean the Army was there
I'd be super specific with that the you
know uh you know Special Operation
special forces were there the Air Force
was there we had Australian
um British you know military it was a
huge Camp creating Naval base and um so
uh two phones for a large group of
people would make the line very long
that you're waiting to be standing there
in hours and then there'd be an incoming
missile everybody'd have to run go take
you know shelter and then cut back I
gave up so I didn't make any photos but
also for me like I you know I was I was
moving forward I didn't have a whole lot
of connections to the past so I I would
just uh
so you get done with your Navy career
you end up as a contractor and this is
so when did you end up like uh going to
school so that was when I was a when I
was a contractor I started so I started
with my I actually went to school to be
a pharmacy tech while I was still on
active duty I was um you know single mom
at the time and um just raising my son
and going to school at night and working
during the day and pharmacy tech seemed
like a good option for me at the time to
have a job when I got out so I finished
that before I got out I started working
at um a compounding pharmacy and very
quickly realized this is not what I want
to do
um went back to school for my bachelor's
in psychology and then started working
towards my master's in that contractor
work so my bachelor's and my Master's
all came after I had separated from the
military so and so yeah I obtained my
masters while I was working as a
contractor and was introduced for my
practicum so in counseling psychology
you have to do some pre-degree and post
degree hours about a total of three
thousand direct like um direct and
indirect clinical hours in order to
obtain your degree and so you get
introduced to various treatment centers
while you're in your school to um
you know get that experience and
practice and that was when I was
actually introduced to Humble Chia which
was owned by Carrie and Carlin at the
time so treatment center for clients
with complex psychiatric disorders and
again
for me at the time I was like this is
just sounds so interesting family
therapy and all of that but in my mind I
was going to school because this was the
school that I could do at night while I
was commuting I was commuting from
Temecula down to Naval Air Station at
the time it was like 72 miles one way
and so I was just kind of moving through
life like it you know just doing the
things that I thought I needed to do to
move forward
and then I met Carrie and Carlin and I
came to know humble Chia and humble Chia
was just this really
special place it was like
I like to call it like a I'm very much
so all about like small business
ownership and like what that means for
our economy and such but Karen Carlin
just they just own this treatment center
and it was not
it was just a a small family owned place
where like people just 100 threw
themselves into helping these families
and I I was drawn to it so much because
the families that were walking through
there were definitely the types of
family it could have been my family
right and and here I was in this place
where really beautiful things were
happening in terms of supporting these
people suffering through very severe
things I mean when you have a loved one
who has a chronic complex psychiatric
disorder something that you're not
getting rid of right we're like making
friends with this we're learning how to
how to um
you know accept it grieve what I thought
was going to be for my kiddo you know
whatever it may be when a family lets
you into their life to like walk through
that path with them it is a very special
thing and I I knew at that point like
okay this is what I want to do I want to
work with families um and I when I
started to realize not in only in my own
life but in what we were doing that we
were creating like generational change
like when you can help a family system
shift away from abuse or addiction or
grief or um
in a way that allows them to Envision a
different identity for themselves like
life could be different like we don't
actually have to keep going in this way
or continue these patterns
I mean you think about the the impact of
that for years and years to come we're
talking about hundreds of people that
could be impacted by one person choosing
to do something different that was like
everything to me and that's what I knew
I wanted to do and it's what I realized
I was able to do for my family in a lot
of ways
um and then this sort of um became my
family when I was there like just I was
able to be seen in a different way it
was like oh we have this new leadership
opportunity like you do it and I'm like
me
and and this is an interesting uh this
is the kind of the intersection between
me and YouTube which is you know I gotta
I got a group of friends and we invest
in a bunch of different things and
um at one point you know my buddy Joe
said hey we're gonna invest in this
we're gonna we're gonna buy some real
estate and it's gonna be used by this
mental health facility and I was like
you know cool I mean literally with them
they just kind of tell me what like they
tell me a three minute hey this is what
we're putting money into I say cool give
them some money we throw it in there and
at some point we invested in sort of a
branch of Hamlet Chia and then that
Branch got swept into Hamlet Chi and the
whole thing got bought and so you know
we we it was a cool situation for us you
know we made money and high-fived and
and then that eventually rolled into
this new Venture which is the a new
treatment center which again I mean I'm
just basically like uh uh I don't want
to say a gambler but a little bit of a
gambler like you're just letting money
roll you know like oh just leave it on
the table and that's kind of what I did
and next thing you know I'm invested in
this uh in this new treatment center and
that's all starting to take place and
um so that's kind of how we all know
each other was from that connection you
know for me just kind of letting my
money sit on the table and and hope it
keeps doing well
um that's that's how we all are uh know
each other but look so
thank you for your backgrounds
um definitely I'm sure we could do a
whole podcast about like each one of
your stories because they there's a lot
there but um I want to kind of get to
the the topic at hand right which is me
trying to get a better understanding of
mental health issues and and you know we
were talking about before we hit record
that
just different things can hit people so
differently and two people can
experience the same literally the same
traumatic traumatic event and have
totally different reactions as as you
were talking Megan I was thinking that
um
like in Seal training the people that
make it through SEAL training are are so
radically different you've got a kid
that grew up with a silver spoon in his
mouth and he makes it through no problem
you got another kid that makes a silver
spoon in his mouth and he quits the
first day you got someone that grew up
on a farm in Iowa and he makes it
through no problem someone else that
grew up on a farm in Iowa and they quit
the first day and everyone in between
you got a kid from the ghetto that that
you know didn't have anything and he
just makes it through some other kid
from the ghetto first day I'm not
putting up with this [__] and that's
so these different lives can have just a
radically different outcome
what are some of the main causes of
mental health issues like what is and I
know there must be several factors I
mean there must be some that are
hereditary you kind of mentioned that
Carlin like there are some hereditary
things then there must be some things
that are brought on by the environment
that you grow up in or what you see so
what what are some of the kind of main
causes
um well there's gosh there's so many
it's hard to to narrow them down and
like I was saying earlier so many of
these things are they're unseen they're
invisible they can't be like located so
much on a map so to speak
um but things like temperament
you know like the kind of the traits and
characteristics that we're born with are
going to play a role
our upbringing of course like I'm
thinking when you would share that story
about being in Kuwait and dig I'm like I
first of all I would have never made it
there but like not I don't think I could
have done that now is it do I not have a
tenacious personality or persevere no
I've got some of that but I think about
my early upbringing right where just
living was hard digging hole to like
survive that would have been at this
whole other level for me so my my
history so people's histories
um messages like in the family like
that's a that and this is my opinion
what's a message what does that mean
like for example
I like to ask families or family members
sometimes so how did you guys do
feelings
[Music]
feelings like
most of the time you're going to have
folks say oh we don't talk about
feelings we we don't actually do
feelings
oh okay so when something
difficult happens you know you get
bullied at school you
your boyfriend breaks up with you
grandma passes away what what did you
guys do
oh nothing we just had dinner you know
right so right here right there's
something
a family that doesn't acknowledge
feelings talk about feelings have a way
to prop like process what was happening
is going to have a certain effect versus
the family you ask and they're like oh
we talked about feelings all the time
anytime something happened we'd sit down
have a big family meeting about it
that person is going to be shaped very
differently in terms of
managing stress and managing conflict
and negotiating hardship
right so so family messages and family
um
almost like traditions around things
like
feelings or how you handle hardship I
mean I'm the book I'm writing right now
has a lot to do with the impact of
Secrets
so and finding that that has a big
um
Secrets like yeah like we don't talk
like if something happens
um
we're just not going to talk about that
we're not going to talk about it amongst
ourselves we're not going to share this
with the outside world under the rug in
the vault whatever you want to call it
so you think about again and not it's
not going to affect everybody the same
way but how easy it would be for a
person then to develop especially if
they're young this idea that like oh
when
when bad things happen or when difficult
things happen you're not supposed to
talk about that you're supposed to keep
it to yourself don't don't share so what
happens for those folks who are faced
with something difficult or faced with a
hard decision or faced with a stressful
circumstance and then it's also so
individual because someone can say oh
you know my grandma died and I'm looking
at my dad and he looks stoic that seems
like a good thing to do that seems like
a good example right yes or oh my
grandma died and my dad looks stoic he
doesn't care and so it's like your
interpretation people's individual
interpretation and even when you were
talking Megan like um when you join the
military or even you saw this recruiter
and you kind of say oh this guy looks
put together and you get the military
and you're like okay here's what I
should be doing and like your perception
of what you're seeing and then your
decision to say oh I I can step up I can
volunteer for this I can make this
happen like just people's own
interaction with reality and what's
going on is so different and
is there a way that you can take people
and show them the positive one does that
does that work is that a is that a thing
to do like let me give you an example I
I have a kids podcast that I do
sometimes and I'll answer kids questions
I've written a bunch of kids books and
one of the one of the questions I got
one time was from a kid and I've got in
multiple forms of this question is and
this actually reminds me of you Carlin
the question was like oh
um
I sometimes kids don't like to hang out
with me and I feel like I'm alone
um
how can I how can I feel better about
that and I answered the question like
hey it's okay to be alone I I'm alone
sometimes and it's okay sometimes you
can be alone and you don't always have
to have people around you and it doesn't
doesn't mean they don't like you it
doesn't mean you're not gonna have
friends just that sometimes you're alone
and that's okay
and I mean that's to me is a legitimate
answer because
you know if let's say let's say your mom
says why are you alone again why don't
you have any friends that might start to
mess you up you know as opposed to your
mom's saying oh you know what are you
reading oh here's a book you know so how
we're interacting and how things uh how
you perceive the world can be so
different that these things and again
you got a kid that grew up in Iowa that
quits and you get a kid that grew up in
Iowa on a farm they both grew up in the
same exact thing one of them quits one
of them makes it right
so
do you as therapists a psychologist get
to try and guide and open and show those
positive things is that what we're doing
here well I think I
we're trying to create some reparative
experiences because when you talk about
the story of the guy who quit or the guy
who went I would be really curious about
his history and past around what
happened when he was struggling when he
was having a hard time or needed to move
through something or didn't know if he
could move forward what was the response
or message that he received in his
environment and the thing about you know
some of these aspects of mental health a
very complex hard to pinpoint exactly
what needs to be but the story that you
just told about this child that response
when someone chooses to lean in and be
vulnerable in a way and ask a question
or look out for support how how we
respond to them is pivotal because it
shapes their experience of whether or
not that's a safe thing to do again in
the future so we talk about like what
cultures or what things influence why
someone might you know keep things to
themselves or be less inclined to share
or come forward if they're struggling
with something
is you know how we respond is huge and
so I you know there's so much aspects of
what's going on for another person that
we don't actually have control over but
we do have control over sort of our own
reaction to when someone is sharing
something with us that appears upsetting
do we want to shut it down and kind of
it should be fine and get moved past it
because that creates an experience for
them or can we kind of tolerate whatever
feelings are coming up for us when we
see one who's someone who's struggling
or with working through something that I
have no idea how to fix or how to
respond to but can I sit with them for
enough time to create an experience for
them that lets them know that like if
something's coming up for me again or if
I need to work through it it's safe to
to come to this person or this
environment is safe enough to be able to
share what's going on for me because if
it's not and that person goes inside
then when we look at more severe things
like suicide or very chronic you know
psychiatric disorders that becomes much
more debilitating in a way that can you
know cost someone their life
I think what you said I also um I so
appreciate it you did it was really good
very lucky
um of how you responded to the kid right
to me I'm like there it is perfect right
as opposed to say a mom or somebody else
that would be like well come on what
what are you doing wrong how come you
don't have any friends friends right
versus like oh I'm sorry to hear that
bud but you know what it's okay it's
okay sometimes to be alone I'm sorry
that you're feeling bad about that today
but okay it's all right there's
something about the like I'm just
acknowledging what you're going through
I'm not trying to change it I'm not
making it wrong I'm not telling you you
should be doing something different and
that's that brings out that safety piece
and in fact some research into
resiliency So speaking to how come some
kids kind of bounce back and get better
and some kids really flounder over here
some of the research shows that there
needs to be opportunities to make
mistakes
and like not be essentially shamed or
made in trouble opportunity to fix them
which means you got to use new skills
and like try and experiment and trial
and error and you need to have at least
one
adult
if you got more that's even better but
you need to have one adult that is kind
of a safe guide like a somebody that you
can feel safe with that's going to kind
of get you and say you know what buddy
it's all right sorry that one did not
work out so well we'll try it again
tomorrow
versus the
shaming you're wrong how come you did
that you should know better like those
kind of things so resiliency is about
having adults especially as kids having
adults that can say yep you know what
sometimes it's just like that I'm sorry
but it's okay you'll be fine
um I had another guy who's a
neuroscientist named Andrew huberman on
here and we were talking about like
winning and losing his kids and he said
it's through your whole life you got to
push yourself you got to lose sometimes
and he actually gave the percentage and
he's got you know research or whatever
he's a Stanford doctor so I guess he's
smart or whatever Andrew but you know we
came down it's like 80 percent of the
time you want the kid to kind of do well
and then 20 of the time they should like
lose if they start what I did with my
kids was lose 90 percent of the time
like put him in really hard situations
and that's not the good way to do it
luckily my kids turned out pretty
resilient but um you know I I was just
like oh you're gonna get beat down it's
Gonna Make You tougher it's gonna make
you stronger and no what happens is they
just start to feel like a loser right so
you got to be careful with that but that
80 I think it's a good number to okay 80
of the time you're winning or you're
evenly matched but you're doing well 20
time you know you got to be pushing
yourself into some situations and that's
the weird thing in like the Seal
training like I'm talking about kids
that were division one wrestlers right
quit
division one wrestling is so insanely
hard
and they have all kinds of hypotheses
you know somebody that was a really good
athlete they've never really been
they've never lost and when you get to
Seal training You're Gonna Lose like
you're gonna you're gonna fail stuff and
so that can be a problem uh with
people's mentality because they've just
never lost before and then there's you
know some kid that's been getting beat
down his whole life he's like oh cool I
failed whatever I'm gonna keep going
um so how do you how do you diagnose you
know again I I made the car mechanic
thing and the cool thing about the
interesting thing about this metaphor is
even a car mechanic you bring your car
and there's a whatever a a tapping noise
in the engine he doesn't necessarily
know 100 words he's like it could be
this could be that he's got to dig in
there so is that the way diagnosis Works
you're sort of like okay
here's a problem you're getting super
emotional
we don't know what's causing it yet
that's the tapping right you're getting
super emotional and then what are we
doing to diagnose how does it happen
pretty much I mean it is a
let's look over here oh that doesn't
really seem to be the problem let's try
this over here now personally what I
have found is
um and not everybody works this way this
is totally fine is
I like to go into how like how how did
you get here right so I'm going to ask
all kinds of questions about what
happened in the family and how were
things talked about and what did you
experience and how was that managed in
the family because I see those things as
they shape so now we have this tapping
that's happening right now where there's
something probably that went on back
then that has to do with it some
therapists some psychologists don't
um they look at like what's happening
right now and how do we move it forward
they're not going to spend a lot of time
in the past it's preference but I mean I
can't tell you how many times what
walked through the door is not what we
ended up finding sure right somebody I
mean my um some of my earlier years in
private practice I worked a lot with
eating disorders
and because I was also still learning
and you know didn't have as much
experience as I would have within a few
years as oh it's meal plan this person
is afraid of getting fat this person
thinks they're more popular if they're
skinny whatever all of these things so
we would kind of Target those behaviors
let's get you on a good meal plan let's
talk about self-esteem
Etc et cetera over the years it was I
mean it was kind of insane how much I
discovered through looking back like
there was trauma in there or some kind
of really defining event that happened
in that young person's life that the
eating disorder behaviors so to speak
were almost like the manifestation
something else what kind of what would
be a something else
um like
um abuse you like often especially with
girls you'd see like a sexual assault or
sexual abuse
um
sometimes that's something that was
happening in the family that was not
being talked about would be
um
kind of stuffed down and then expressed
through these behaviors so almost
psychologically you can interpret that a
little bit as if we're spending all of
our time over here on meal plans and
weight gain and weight loss what are we
not looking at
the secret over here that nobody wants
to talk about right so sometimes finding
An Origin
um
that then explains the symptoms
then you treat the origin the issue over
here versus the symptoms right kind of
like the analogy I've used a million
times even with clients is if you come
in with like a Civ like with pneumonia a
severe case of pneumonia and the only
thing we're doing is giving you some
cough syrup
to help your cough
like that's going to help a little bit I
mean it's going to help you feel a tiny
bit better but nothing in fact you might
even get worse if we don't really treat
the thing that's really underneath the
cough like the cough actually isn't
really the issue well this is another
thing yeah this is the really humanizing
part in terms of what you're talking
about because I think we have to be
really Mindful and responsible with as
clinicians with how we talk about the
use of diagnoses you know in my private
practice I often get people coming to me
that it's their first time they've
reached out for mental health services
they've gone somewhere and they've met
spent just a short meeting with someone
and they were given a diagnosis bipolar
disorder something that's very severe
you know they go look this up on the
Internet they start attaching all these
things to their personality
and now you know I am bipolar disorder I
you know have I start to attach these
like things to my personality and that
language is very powerful over time
because if I am something or something
is happening to me I have much less
control over how I respond to it as Expo
as opposed to this idea that um I'm
experiencing some symptoms associated
with bipolar disorder or I'm
with this or you know after some
reflection and I've I've I have an
address trauma in my past that's showing
up like you know very volatile outbursts
or something like that and so I think
you know how we talk about it is really
important
um because nowadays and if you have kids
my age there's plenty of kids walking
around self-diagnosed as OCD or
depression or these sorts of things
because they hear about something and I
am this and I can't do this because I
have this and
um so I think one of the first things we
try to do with people is start to talk
about like the impact and history
because it allows us to create a
framework to talk about things that are
more humanizing as opposed to
um
you know the symptoms or like a label
right right sure so this made me think
of something that I said a while ago
um I looked up the definition of being
insane and being insane was when your
your reality doesn't match the reality
of the world right and I was right we
have a online training program and I was
telling you I said hey everyone is
insane right everyone is to some level
insane because
if the three of us witness an event or
participate in an event it's going to be
a little bit different for all of us
like our our reality is going to be a
little bit different well no you said
this I didn't say that I said this so
we're going to have different
interpretations of reality so everyone
therefore is a little bit insane right
and it's just how insane are you
and when when you start looking at that
like this the the most the horrifying
thing
um like anorexia where
the person is so clearly
malnutritioned and so clearly like 100
of people in the world would say you
need to eat more and that one person the
the person that has it just they just
don't see that
that's got to be the scariest
scariest environment like for a parent I
can't even fathom what that's what
that's doing
um so as you you're talking about Carlin
you're talking about
addressing the the like finding this
original this initial problem
and that's what we're able how we're
able to address that
bring that into the light get that thing
solved and it solves the symptom that
we're all seeing pretty much I mean and
that's the mechanic work right is you're
you're kind of digging and and you know
sometimes the person will know like I
had this thing happen and I think my
symptoms are related to this sometimes
they're not aware I had a a young girl
that I was treating for anorexia she was
a cheerleader Anna ballerina
so so much pressure right to maintain
this very malnourished very thin body
and all the guilt like even you know
eating something that had a carb in it
you know just like I can't I'm gonna get
that I'm not going to get picked I mean
so destructive and um interfering with
life
so I'm working with her and I'm trying
the dentist thing and this thing and
we're trying over here and want to know
your worth isn't wrapped up in your
ballerina so nothing is not focused on
the physical life at the time you look
fine because this is all she was
presenting with is like I I know like
it's almost like I know I I this is not
a good for me I just don't really know
what to do about it but there wasn't
really much else tried getting the
parents and they didn't want to come in
which really should have been my first
clue and long story short just to to get
to this point is months and months of
meeting with her and like what about
this and I don't know what about that
she says well
um you know my mom
said she didn't want me to talk about
this but I I feel like I should
I think I was molested by my cousin when
I was like 12. I'm like
oh so I'm like here we go so I'm asking
her all these questions and you know she
just tells this
really very sad
um kind of horrible story about
learning that she like learning
something at school that made her think
oh my God I think that happened to me
going home telling her parents and her
parents like do not tell anybody about
this this is going to ruin everybody's
life right just don't talk about it
well no the poor now she's a ballerina
right like all that got
um stuffed down and kind of channeled in
this way that she could control her
environment a lot of time
um a lot of the time so we start
unpacking this and it turns out as she
tells me about this event that made her
think that she might have been molested
that's not what happened she was in some
class at school and they were talking
about something and she like almost like
misinterpreted so this for years there
was this whole thing that had happened
in her family where she said she had
been molested but she really she really
wasn't
they thought she was shut it down didn't
let anybody talk about it and now she's
coming in for treatment for anxiety and
an eating disorder right as soon as we
got there and we got it and she was I
mean she bought in she was like oh my
God I had no idea at this point she's
maybe 18. I think I started seeing I was
just 15.
like all of a sudden it was like all
that symptomology went away
I mean it didn't vanish overnight
because she'd been doing those behaviors
for a long time but that Clarity of like
oh this is what this was about this
being made to be wrong you know I
thought this bad thing had happened to
me and I was like essentially
punished for it and told that if I tell
and something happens to my cousin it's
gonna like be my fault so not being able
to talk about it being told by her mom
don't go talk about this in therapy
do you want to go to there before right
but but it was that like that's an
example of you kind of we just had to
peel and peel and ask questions and when
we found it it cleared up because right
like you said it like it kind of brought
it into the light we could address what
the real problem was and then the
symptoms the cough so to speak
alleviated because the the root the core
had been addressed so there is a lot in
in psychological practice and treatment
that does involve some and it's a huge
years three years yeah I saw every week
because she and she was really like
I was told not to talk about this
so she kind of knew something was back
there but she was also young and had
been directed by her family don't talk
about this if you talk about this and
she calls the school and your cousin
gets in trouble then aunt and uncle are
like like you know the so just
but it was what was if you can go into
it a little bit like what because you
said it didn't really happen but you
thought it happened well yeah so she
said she was at school one day and they
were doing one of these assemblies right
where you're giving like the kids
education on you know healthy touch an
inappropriate touch like so you know
maybe she's 15 at this time she was also
very immature only child
a little bit sheltered so
maturity why she was a little little
behind I think and so she said so I this
thing was happening and I told my friend
oh my God I think I might have been
molested because this thing happened
with my cousin-law so I'm like okay so
can you tell me what happened with your
cousin so she tells me this event which
was really like
at a party one night like all the
cousins and aunts and uncles the kids
decided to like like play a joke in like
skinny dip like they all went to the
pool house like stripped off their
clothes and like ran into the pool and
made a big joke and everyone got in
trouble because the parents were there
and this kind of thing and she goes it
was my cousin's idea
okay
so like he molested me right I'm like
what what
in her mind she had because she heard
this thing at school and her friend said
oh my God it was your cousin that said
you should take off your bathing so I
think that's my last I think that's
inappropriate whatever like it grew into
this thing but when she really when we
went back and walked through the event
she goes well no it was it was my
cousin's idea but like we all did it no
one no one touched anybody it was we
thought it would be funny so tragic I
mean this is this what to me and she did
once we got there she did beautifully
she's off at College I mean doing
wonderfully but the years right of a
misunderstanding of something that
happened it was like the telephone game
right she told this person they told
this they it just by the time it arrived
at parent her parents it was this whole
other thing
scary it's so scary uh Megan something
you were talking about when you're
talking about oh people's kind of
self-diagnosed at some point or they get
a diagnosis from somebody and oh yeah we
had a friend of mine on here there's an
ancient uh Native American saying that
something along the lines of
it's not a diagnosis it's a curse like
if you get diagnosed with something and
you you can hear it as a curse like this
is what you are
uh
how much play does it give to me I mean
well obviously I wrote a book called
Extreme ownership taking ownership of
like what's going on in your world and
instead of being oh I'm bipolar that's
what I am it's like no I have some
symptoms symptoms and here's how I'm
going to get control of this right is
that something that comes into play in
getting people moving in the right
direction I would say absolutely yes I
mean because what we're trying to do is
help people
um you know identify differently with
what's happening in their life or create
a new narrative or story around what's
going on in their life so I mean this
happens not just with the individual but
with families right like if I'm if I
hear that my kiddo who's historically
done really well you know they're
talented they've done it well in music
all through high school all of a sudden
they're in their first or second year of
college and they're starting to display
some really interesting symptoms they
have their first psychotic break it's
like devastating for a family like what
happened it's very common around that
age frame for something like this to
happen
all of these ideas start coming up about
my son has schizophrenia he'll he'll
never be able to get married he'll he'll
never be able to hold down a job we're
never going to see our son graduate from
college we're not going to be able to do
the family vacations you just say it
just goes on and on and so you sit with
these families and there's just such a
sense of hopelessness and so what we try
to do is is come back a little bit to
say like well you know why don't you
think he's able to live alone well he
hasn't taken out the trash all week his
his room is a mess he stays in there all
by himself well how come how is he able
to do that like how is he able to sit in
his room all day and like not experience
the natural consequences Associated if I
went in my room all day stop going to
school or work or whatever it may be
like things would fall apart in my life
how is that able to happen and so
what we can get to and this takes a lot
of time is essentially the fear
associated with like if I was to to push
him towards something or if he he's not
capable or because of this illness now
he can't do this and we have to really
unpack and it's different for every
family but we have to really unpack that
to figure out what it is that they've
decided collectively this means for
their life right these symptoms or this
diagnosis and then help them Envision
something sort of different for
themselves and then create experiences
for individuals to play that out well
he's been taken out the trash all week
here and if he doesn't his peer tells
him like hey you didn't take out the
trash and so go do that or experience
some of the natural consequences
associated with if I've just leave my
stuff everywhere you know that my
roommate tells me like hey you know this
room like stinks can you like clean this
up like some of that peer-to-peer
interaction but we have to create those
opportunities for that and then
interestingly when people start to
engage in this it's not like a cognitive
like oh yeah I'll go do this thing and
something will be different it's usually
more like I act I have have these
experiences I walk through something
difficult my symptoms got really
activated when I was going to go try to
learn how to take the bus or do the
trolley but you know what like I had
somebody with me and I was able to do it
and it was like okay and it didn't stay
that way forever and then so the the
kind of the Insight comes a little bit
later with the experience that like I
can experience some discomfort or I can
let my kiddo struggle a little bit or go
through something and I can actually
tolerate some of my fear that this could
be like devastating for him because you
know oftentimes
when we get to it especially for
families who have you know we're we're
sort of um in a good place if a family's
coming to us at a first break because we
can help them like right there but
oftentimes people come to us 14
hospitals last resort type thing 14
hospitalizations in multiple short-term
treatment centers break look like what's
that what's that look like I mean it
looks like a break from reality it's
different for each person you know that
process sometimes can appear like what
you see more often in like movies and
such sort of bizarre or paranoia or I
see aliens who sometimes for people with
significant personality disorders and
this way like delusions can be grounded
almost in something like that feels real
like it could be a real situation but
it's in fact not when you get too down
to it so
um but ultimately it's just a disconnect
from what's happening in the here and
now in a lot of different ways and it
could be auditory it could be tactile in
terms of a person's you know experience
of what they're feeling in their body
maybe visual just a break from reality a
break from reality So a family they got
a 18 year old kid a 20 year old kid
they're in college they're going to
college everything's fine and then all
of a sudden just give me an example what
does this look like so I mean for
example what it might look like is
they're calling home and like my
neighbors are they're they're listening
to me my neighbors are really bothering
me like they're they're listening
through the walls I know that they're
doing these things so this is like an
obvious
I mean it could be yes or it could be as
a parent you're hearing this you're like
that's really odd like why would the
neighbors be listening to them or so
sometimes this can go on for a period of
time where there's like some things that
you know you notice some more isolation
or not hanging out with friends as much
or maybe there's some substance use that
is sort of new and so it's not always so
like it's obvious yeah it might not be
like the neighbors are watching me it
might be like I'm not doing anything
this weekend yeah or even how many times
we've had um like somebody come into the
treatment program and the parents say
well we thought everything was great
he's at College like he's seems like
he's fine but we started getting calls
from his friends okay we think
something's going on it's not really
coming out anymore or seems to be
hanging out in his room all the time but
then we call him and he says he's okay
right but so there's this like I we
don't really know what's going on and
how many times we've had I don't know
you know family sales so we just decided
to like get in the car and drive up
there and see what was going on for
ourselves and they find their kid like
disheveled maybe haven't been eating so
what's going on with that kid
well like what's an example of okay I
get the call hey your son is he's hey
hey you know Billy Billy's not come out
with us for like three weeks we haven't
even seen him we just want to call you
and let you know like he's really been
acting weird and so I call Billy and
Billy says no I'm fine I just been
studying really hard and it's just been
a pain in school and I'm really sick of
Fred anyways so I'm just doing my own
thing oh okay
and then you know I get another call
it's his ex-girlfriend you know I just I
saw him the other day he just looked
totally different so I drive up there
and there he is in his room um his room
is a mess what's going on with him what
what is it is it a is it something that
he saw is it something that got
triggered is it
like what is it do we know
sometimes we do and sometimes we won't
and this is where like the mechanic has
to come in right and figure it out
sometimes it's going to be very obvious
like
a more common scenario that we've
experienced is like everything was fine
star athlete blah blah blah goes to
college seems to be making friends
decided to start smoking weed a little
bit and then boom right it set something
off again some people can smoke weed
that will not happen
um you know there's some
Theory and hypothesis that some people
um
you can be like predisposed
for schizophrenia or psychosis but it
not necessarily come out but it will
under certain conditions and sometimes
drug use is one of those so you can have
somebody who's predisposed like has
genetic loading and and never kind of
becomes
somebody who has a genetic
predisposition and they go to college
and they start smoking a little weed and
it like
crack something open internally and here
it comes but it could be a girlfriend
breakup it could be
um you know they didn't get into the
Frat or whatever disappointment just
something like that and this can in some
cases people can just kind of they're
they're changing and sometimes it goes
away naturally
okay sometimes it's like oh yeah he was
bummed out for a few weeks but hey we
just saw Billy he's he's actually he's
coming down here yeah sure yeah and it's
and it's we can get a person can get
through it
sure we've had folks come in like the
one person I'm thinking about was um I
think he was in his freshman year at
College again a great student
scholarship to uh football I mean just a
lot of friends great girl like just
really kind of all around and they got a
call the parents got a call from the
police the local police and his um their
son's town that they found him like
running around outside like half naked
like kind of kind of crazy screaming and
doing weird things and they're like did
you call the right people that is not my
kid
well he had smoked he had never done
drugs or you know maybe he had a little
bit but smoked weed and he couldn't he's
like I don't know someone just gave it
to me so who who knows what was in there
well it did something to this guy's
brain I mean it just scrambled him he
did not know what way was up or down
went to the hospital
they brought him to us for treatment
never been in treatment I mean had never
had anything happen like this before he
was um he was back in school I think by
the next semester like he needed he came
in you know we got him settled kind of
walked through what happened as soon as
the um the drugs were out of his system
which didn't take a long time because he
wasn't really a chronic user he cleared
like he instantly cleared in his mind so
in that case
diagnosis rise it was a substance
induced psychosis
substance induced psychosis so as soon
as the substances were out of a symptom
out of his system
he there was no more psychosis he
cleared so really it was just helping
him almost like recover from I mean that
was a traumatic event and he was
embarrassed and had all the shame and
you know there was like a lot of stuff
he had to kind of process and recover
from and then he went back to college
same school well an early intervention
there is super early because you know
the further away the intervention the
person starts to find ways to
self-soothe or whatever might be and it
becomes much more complex at that point
so if someone has one episode they're
easier to help than someone that's had
28. we had parents were just like oh
he'll be fine oh it's just Billy he's
just he acts up sometimes and then that
goes on for three four five years he's
gonna be harder to treat or the brain
stays in a constant state of psychosis
for a longer period of time it's hard to
know what it's going to look like when
they come out of that right ex explained
what psychosis actually means
there we go yeah well it's um well you
had said it earlier it's a break in
reality it's like psychosis typically is
defined as a
a break in contact with reality and
what's interesting though about
psychosis and I say this in the the
um
presentation and in the book is
people can be Psycho people can be
psychotic have a psychotic episode and
not be related to a mental illness right
what would that look like uh anesthesia
like under anesthesia people have
reported hallucinating
malnourishment and dehydration somebody
can hallucinate Hear Voices have
delusions sleep deprivation sleep
deprivation 100
um so there are still trying to keep you
awake and you know we'd be surprised if
you are seeing some things that maybe
are not actually there yeah I was out on
the boat in the middle of the ocean and
I thought I saw like traffic's lights
and I was like hey we gotta stop you
know and I actually knew that I was
hallucinating I was like that can't be
real because I'm in the ocean but that
definitely is a stoplight and I think we
should stop but that doesn't make any
sense so head injury
um
so psychotic event is when you're you're
disconnected from reality in a big way
yeah like a break and kind of the
contact in reality like
seeing something that isn't there
feeling hearing something or delusion
right like a belief that somebody's
following me somebody's watching me
um somebody's out to get me I I was
telling one of my friends the other day
as a in supervision that one of my very
first patients who had schizophrenia and
he was pretty severe had a belief that
he was like
every once in a while he was
reincarnated as somebody else so but
like you know sometimes he would talk
about that like funny he would be like
when I told you I thought I was
Ram Das I'm like I do remember that he's
like wow that was really weird oh my god
oh so he kind of knew it and then he
wouldn't like then sometimes he wouldn't
he'd be like so in it and very like
fixed that you you really couldn't
um
kind of talk him out of it so to speak
so here I'm going to open up just the
biggest can of worms what the hell
happens when I'm on on the internet and
social media and I'm starting to think
that I'm a little bit
conspiratorial and I start reading
reading various websites that are just
totally
you know read it which is like a website
that has a bunch of different random
things I mean I guess they all do I mean
you can go down you can do any Reddit
YouTube any one of these things you can
go watch something on YouTube that if
you have a little bit of an indication
that the world might be flat you guys
heard of flat earthers yeah they're out
there yeah they're this flat and there's
videos upon videos upon threads upon
threads of the Earth is flat so if you
have a little bit of paranoia about
something
that can't be good for you you have to
be really mindful of that the internet
that is a dangerous place I mean like
WebMD self-diagnosing oh yeah yeah yeah
um
do how bad is that like I mean you talk
about oh uh somebody can smoke weed how
bad is it if I think you know what I
really think that there's a world order
that's trying to keep me down well I
mean I think it depends on the person
and their ability to sort of like
self-moderate their exposure to stuff
like that because if if you're in a
healthier place and you can moderate
your exposure to that you realize gosh I
just spent two hours scrolling through
this super unhealthy I'm not feeling
good and I can set some sort of
boundaries for myself around that then
like what's it's positive you know I
think we all have the tendency towards
Indulgence in some ways
um but for someone who struggles with
that or who's coming to us and like
every time they turn on the news there's
a significant amount of paranoia for
them and that causes them to act in
response to those delusions or thoughts
in a way that's like harmful to them or
others well then we help moderate some
of that you know a lot of the treatment
that we do and why it takes so much time
is creating some scaffolding around
things like that so that people can
develop that Insight if it's not readily
available to them because with something
like schizophrenia I mean it's a thought
disorder it's impacting your cognition
your ability to think in a lot of ways
and so if someone is not able to
self-regulate in that way we help create
some scaffolding for them so like maybe
we're not watching the news at five
tonight because that's not going to end
up good because every time you do you
end up out on the streets or whatever it
might have been in America you just
don't want me to watch the news because
you don't really know what's going on
because you're part of the conspiracy a
lot of times which is why it's so
important to to build a sense of Rapport
and safety with someone to be consistent
in what you're doing and have an
environment that's consistent so that
people feel safe enough to allow you to
support them and and and they will in a
lot of ways with time but the work that
we do is not a quick fix people spend a
long period of time with us
um and uh so that we can develop enough
safety where they will buy into trying
some of the things that we're requesting
might be you know or suggesting might be
helpful for them
um and so that then they can develop
some of their own Insight like oh wow I
haven't had this much paranoia or I
haven't been this kind of undone for a
period of time and I also haven't
watched the news for this period of time
like maybe that is helpful for me and
then usually when they come to the
latter part of their time or their
Journey where they're more um in like a
an outpatient type setting they can
reflect back some of those things like I
didn't like the structure that you put
me on or I didn't like this particular
thing but I realize now why that was so
helpful for me do people have to be uh
open to wanting to change in order to
change
and if you have someone that's just like
the parent put them in there the 23 year
old kid hey look you're going in here
you're gonna get fixed
that's all over from our
from Marshall Lee when you're working
with something like a thought disorder
like schizophrenia a systemic
containment is incredibly helpful and
systemic containment meaning that the
family is helping to support some sort
of boundaries around the options that
the child has in a lot of ways because
sometimes people will come to us and
their their kiddo has schizophrenia that
they don't want to come to treatment
they don't want to do these things they
they don't want to do some things that
are going to help them wait the kid
doesn't the kid doesn't but yet
um and the family's like I don't know
what to do he doesn't want to come it's
like well you know how does he have this
car or how does he have this apartment
he's like not able to work and so we
help the family really create some
structures around like um sort of some
boundaries in a way of like I'm here to
support you and I'm going to help you on
this journey within the context of this
realm that's going to be helpful for you
exactly so a lot of times when when
folks come they aren't necessarily happy
to be there but they just don't have a
lot of options and we really work with
family extended family grandparents what
not to be like don't send that 500 check
because if you do I know you feel bad
and he doesn't have any money he's
probably going to be out on the streets
drinking or whatever it might be and so
we work with as many people as we can to
create a nice safe container in some
ways which is the treatment environment
because with what we do it's not a
locked setting it's it's a sort of the
least restrictive type of environment in
a residential setting but it requires a
ton of containment and support from
every member of like the community
that's working there in the family to
make sure that there's a path and maybe
there's a couple options to the path but
it's really clear in their Titan
contained so that the person can
actually have some experiences and we
can calm down some of the things that
are happening in these symptoms so that
they can begin to develop some of their
own Insight or understanding as to why
and sometimes
um you know the hardest part about the
work that we do is that you can want to
help someone you can want to save them
you can
want to and and and they might not want
that and it might not be the choice that
they have for themselves and we've had
to you know walk through losses in that
way as well you know so I do think there
is a component of um that person wanting
some of that and even if somebody on the
surface doesn't want it uh families and
the people around them can do a lot to
create an environment for them where
they can grow in that desire for
themselves
um and you know sometimes people don't
so this is like a tough love scenario in
some way or am I right sure it's like a
tough love scenario so sometimes you
know I've Got Friends
and they might be having a hard time
with whatever you know maybe they're
they're drinking or they're do they're
not doing what they should be doing
and I think most of the time
what they need is bro what are you doing
you're being an idiot stop doing that
and they go yeah man you know what I'm
being an idiot I need to stop doing that
it seems like that's a vast majority of
the time of what people need what scares
me is you know if I say wait what are
you doing you're being an idiot
and they really do have like some
significant issue that they don't have
any control over that they can't help
and all of a sudden I was just the worst
friend ever by saying dude you're being
a wimp just get over it and move forward
and they think
oh Jocko saying I'm a wimp that means I
really am a wimp that means I'm not good
enough that and they go down I worried
that they would go down a spiral
as opposed to hey man stop acting like
that hey quit blaming quit blaming this
incident on the way you're acting now
you know you you need to go you need to
show up to work on time you need to get
a job you need to stop drinking all
sometimes like that's and I think
actually most of the time people just
need like bro what are you doing and I'm
talking bro because these are my friends
um that are dudes
um even though oddly enough my daughters
call each other bro
yeah and they call all their friends bro
that are all females they got it down
yeah so so but but
is there some way to to discern whether
whether someone's crossed the line into
okay listen tough love isn't going to
help this individual anymore and I need
to get them some real help because
that's a scary thing you know you you
know I'll experience that with a person
that I know an acquaintance that I have
a friend that I have that oh you know
he's
not looking good right stop working out
which to me is a big indicator of well
stop working out doesn't you know not to
really eating like crap and she seems to
be drinking a lot
and what I want to say and what I have
said to do guys is
bro what are you doing why are you why
are you not working out you're getting
fat what are you doing like how much you
drinking are you drinking every night
what's wrong with you get back on the
path like stop and oftentimes they're
like yeah but I've been so lazy I need
to I've been thinking about this thing
but you're right I need to keep going
but then I get the feeling sometimes
it's like it's deeper and worse
is there any way to discern is there any
warning signs to look out for between
these two individuals one of whom needs
this good kick in the ass that's going
to get them moving in the right
direction
and the other one I kicked them in the
ass they're gonna fall down the stairs
and it's going to hurt them yeah
discernment is important in knowing
people's history and such especially in
the work we do I think it's different
you know when you're looking from a
clinical perspective but discernment is
huge and at the same time I think one of
the hardest things in loving or caring
about somebody who's struggling with
something is that we don't necessarily
have control over how they respond to
what we try to give them and so you know
coming from a place of if if my Approach
is is tough love in terms of what you're
describing and like what you're you're
being honest and true to yourself and
can also add that other part of like
there's a part of me that's sort of
fearful that if I have tough love on you
that's like this is going to go kind of
sideways for you does that feel true for
you and just sort of being direct and
honest with people I mean I think people
can feel congruency they can feel care
and tough love if it's coming from a
place that's like love it's felt very
differently than something that's
critical or mean or suggests like you're
gonna cut you off from my life if if you
don't you know do this thing that's very
different so when we talk about tough
love and oftentimes it is working
families to be like this isn't me and
this is actually the most loving thing
you could do for this person because to
say no nothing or to let them continue
on in a way where their life is just
deteriorating well that would be
horrible right so like to do nothing
um would be very harmful and so I don't
think I mean this is the hardest thing
about severe mental illness is that we
can trial out we can say a lot we can do
things we don't necessarily have control
over what somebody's going to do with
the feedback that we give them
um and this risk too there's there's
definitely risk involved in doing some
of those things and it doesn't always
you know have a positive outcome to set
boundaries and things like that and at
the same time I think being congruent is
like most important and I think what you
said earlier about Rapport like I think
about some of the clients I've seen for
the longest I mean I have relationships
with these people I know these guys you
know these guys like I can tell
like and I can because I have Rapport I
always joke like you've heard me say
this in supervision like I'm sometimes
surprised myself with how much I can get
away with saying right because I have
enough Rapport where I know the person's
going to be able to handle it even if
it's something like I have a client this
literally just happened I said
you sound like a crazy person right now
she's like I know don't I I said you
kind of do now I wouldn't say that to
ever
yeah if I didn't have that kind of
relationship with a different client I'm
not going to say that that could be
construed as like rude and very not PC
right but with her I can say like you're
doing that thing right now or you just
you kind of sound and look like a crazy
person can you pull it together and
she's like okay you know we move on but
if I were to say that to her say one
afternoon and she she can't pull it
together or she how dare you say that to
me or she you know reacts in a way
that's different than my experience of
her typically you know that's going to
be my Discerning clue of like okay this
might be something a little bit more
then she's just you know having a moment
like I know her enough or I know him
enough to know like
oh I kind of pulled the like come on get
your [__] together I know you can do
this
and it works and the times when it seems
to not really be working then it's just
my clue that okay there maybe is
something a little bit more happening
here so I'm gonna I'm just gonna like
change my Approach a little bit slow it
down and maybe ask more questions
instead of say hey come on get it
together and move on it might be like so
what's happening because you seem
different to me today than you did last
week what's going on I might
ask a little bit more to see if more
comes out but the um I think there's a
place for both and people really espec
especially people who are very
disorganized internally which you'll see
more with psychosis or just in a funk in
their depression in their grief whatever
whatever
they need the they need actually like
the scaffolding on the outside somebody
to say okay you know what you need to
get up
go take a shower brush your teeth meet
me in the kitchen in 15 minutes
like that kind of Direction actually
helps gel some of the looseness that's
happening internally when someone's
really struggling and then there's going
to be times hopefully when that's not
needed that they can do that for
themselves
from uh
this is sort of uh I guess parallel or
at least adjacent to the Social Media
stuff we were talking about this the
idea that we did a podcast on social
contagions right which is and I think
one of the best examples that I read
about was bulimia and with the first
reported case of bulimia was in 1979 or
something like this I forget the dates
but
you know this guy did did a article
about these girls who were making
themselves sick and there was you know
three or four girls that he did this
report on and
after that like the number of cases went
completely through the roof
um same thing with uh cutting like uh
this happens with young females a lot
they cut themselves but it'll spread
through a through a community or through
a friendship group of girls happens with
suicide you know there's this thing
where and this this always scares me
because you know doing a podcast like
what we're doing today and a lot of
people are going to listen to this
uh when they put up
anti-suicide or or suicide help hotline
numbers in a community oftentimes the
suicide rate increases because now it's
putting it in their mind
how much do you how much have you all
seen of that in the last you know 10
years and I guess it's maybe even less
than that seven years of where people
are so connected to social media where
oh you know what Billy's depressed and
he seems like he's got getting a lot of
attention for being depressed and I kind
of you know I I'm I I didn't have
anything to do on Friday night and so
I'm probably not that popular I'm
actually going to be depressed too how
much is that impacting people because
let's face it you know 100 years ago
people weren't talking about this and so
what were they doing you know like oh
I'm depressed but that's just the way I
feel and there's they even have a name
for it so guess what they did they went
to work and they carried on and maybe
they didn't feel great but they carried
on
what what role is this total
connectedness that we have and then and
you know we all can't even compare to
the young to the 15 year olds
that are connected like 100 of the time
that they're awake they're connecting
and being influenced by everyone else in
the world
what impact are you all seeing from that
okay it's substantial and I think it is
um with the onset I in fact I think it
around like when smartphones oh yeah
that's where I kind of like the internet
was already there you could go online
and look at a bunch of stuff but at your
fingertips and now with um you know
Instagram and all the I mean you're just
constantly looking who's doing what
who's saying what who's endorsing what
who's against what and the the
attachment to all of that
um and also the social disconnect like
from other human beings versus instead
of having a conversation with you or
asking you your opinion about something
or going to you to talk about something
that might be on my mind I'm looking to
see who's saying what and what are other
people doing about it which is
influencing my feed and all the things
that are coming up yeah like how many
like I didn't get as many likes as you
got what does that mean about me
um in addition to what you were saying
earlier about like the self-diagnosing
oh I read it you know how many times
especially with the adolescence I see
oh I read an article I think I have a CD
in my mind
no you don't let's talk about that or oh
I read an article and this is happening
to me so I think I might have stomach
cancer
it's
we'll send you to the doctor if you want
to have that checked out but let's talk
about your that you woke up with a
stomach ache because you have a job
interview this afternoon that you kind
of don't want to go to
let's talk about that instead but no I
looked online I looked online if you
wake up at the stomach ache it means
this right so this whether it's looking
up symptoms and diagnoses or what this
means or what other people are doing or
what other people are saying about what
other people are doing it's just
um it's like it's defined right yes it's
self-diagnosis becomes self-fulfilling
prophecy as well and the person's you
know what they're they're out their
world outside of social media looks like
their family how much they can you know
cross-reference the things that they're
seeing on there with like a parent who's
telling them like let's think about that
let's let's walk that through like if
depending on how much exposure they have
to that outside of that world is going
to make a big difference in terms of the
impact of being engrossed in the social
media world because not all
um kiddos have a family who's willing to
talk them through all the things that
they're seeing on social media help them
discern what they read these sorts of
things so definitely a balance outside
of that is is necessary to combat the
influence within social media there's
also the part of
having things just available right right
now right now is like I think about when
I went growing up like there were no
there were I didn't even we didn't have
an answering machine like if you wanted
to call somebody you called them and if
they were there they would pick up and
if they weren't they didn't like that
was it you called them back later there
was no
texting that like there was no this
immediacy so thinking about not having
that immediate gratification
I and people in my generation and people
who didn't have access to some of these
things developed
um patience and tolerance skills like I
could wait even if I really really
really want to talk to you like I can I
can wait and not fall apart
I had a client while I still see her but
when she was younger her parents are
fantastic she is like very
self-diagnosed he has no tolerance for
delayed gratification or patience
because everything right everything is a
an immediate answer if I text you and
you have not if I see the dots and then
you don't get back to me like you know
this kind of thing so she did something
and got herself in trouble so her
parents took her phone
she said if you take my phone I'm gonna
kill myself
I can't not have my phone they put her
in the car and took her to the emergency
room I thought that was the most
brilliant thing ever and of course by
the time they walk in she's like never
mind I won't kill myself I'll give my
phone back whenever you want to give it
to me but it was that instant like I
can't I can't live like I cannot not
have my phone
and she has no
um emotional like man at the time like
no emotional management skills how old
she was probably 15 or 16 at this point
like old enough
um but I think about all the parents
that would be like oh oh my okay never
never mind yeah right and so now you
just reinforced
that if you're upset or you don't think
you can handle something just I'll make
it easy for you so that
um
a delay of gratification managing
anxiety tolerating waiting and then what
do you do right like if I want to talk
to you and you're not answering the
phone
um I'm not going to just like sit there
like right now people sit there right
they sit on their phone versus like you
go do something to manage your anxiety
or your distress at not being able to
talk to your person like we like I grew
up with that people
um nowadays they're in a lot of ways are
lacking in those skills of just managing
their feelings because they don't have
to have you heard the expression left on
red have you even heard of this so it's
when my kids talking about yeah so it's
when you're
you know I send you a message Carlin and
I get a thing that says you read it yeah
but you don't respond to me so you just
left me on you read it but you don't
respond like it's devastating it's
catastrophic number one to not get an
immediate response and then to be left
on red is like you might as well have
been canceled as the other term so so
this stuff is going to impact people I
mean that's an impact psychologically
yes huge because we're just expecting
everyone to maintain connection all the
time and soothe me when like when I'm
upset you need to reply so I don't have
anxious feelings and the social media
companies are creating these things like
Tick Tock is created to be as addictive
as possible as humanly possible so it's
immediate gratification 100 of the time
it's like boom boom boom boom boom and
you can't put that thing down
this is a nightmare isn't it well and
you see it show up a lot and folks
coming into work younger ages between 20
to 24 and you you're referred to a lot
as like being entitled right you hear
this term entitlement thrown a lot like
this generation is entitled entitlement
and such but when you really look at
what's going on
um there's very poor distress tolerance
skills like if there's something I need
to wait on or I'm waiting for an answer
from my manager for something or you
know something needs to change it
clearly needs to grow in the
organization but um you know it's taking
some time to work through these things
like there's an immediate sort of
narrative that something must be wrong
that this is a really negative thing
people don't care about me or whatever
that person goes through in their poor
distress tolerance and it creates all
kinds of issues and then if I can't
tolerate it well what do I do I just
leave or I check out or stop caring
about what I'm doing or you know I can
justify misusing company resources or
not really using my time I mean there's
all kinds of interesting things that
come from it but at the core
um at least I'm not an expert on this at
all but it's just a very poor distress
tolerance and watching my kids work
through some of that stuff where if you
know someone didn't reply to them like
they like it felt sort of catastrophic
and helping them think through like what
could possibly be some other options as
to why someone might not have responded
and usually a few days later it's like
oh it's everything everything's cool mom
uh so-and-so got their phone taken away
so oh okay so that's why they didn't
respond to you you know and your kids
are freaking out I'm thinking that's the
end of the world something bad is
happening for sure yeah
um can we talk through some mental
health issues I got I read through a
bunch of these um anxiety disorder
fear and dread
what's a what's a cause for that
so many potential causes for that but I
mean ultimately it's a it's a state in
which you're sort of um
ing or maybe anticipating that something
very negative is going to happen right I
have this I would use a job interview
coming up and you know I really need
this job but I'm definitely going to say
something wrong and I'm going to trip I
mean it's just can sort of uh roll in
that direction with a person's thoughts
in a lot of ways and then in their body
can feel
sick sick to my stomach look like
somatic symptoms so people express it in
a lot of different ways some you'll see
a lot of thoughts related to it that are
very sort of negative in anticipating
something sort of horrible is going to
happen or not work out well and in some
ways for for some people it's very
physical they're sick all the time or
often getting a cold or you know they're
you know these sorts of things so
um and it's like a chain so if it's a
sort of a job interview right well I
don't know what if I say the wrong thing
what if they ask me a question I don't
know well what if they don't like me
what if I don't get the job what like
what if what it's that kind of chaining
together it's the next thing you know
like I
I might as well just not even I might as
well kill myself I mean it can go it can
go in a lot of different ways but the um
this like persistent
worry and anticipation that is not
um proportionate to the situation like
it's it's one thing to have some
nervousness I have this big job
interview I really want this job I hope
they like me I'm a little bit
like my stomach hurts a little bit
that's one thing but that disproportion
um and that chaining together of all of
the like things that could potentially
happen so go ahead I would say it's like
the difference too between I think most
of us experience some level of anxiety
around things it can actually be really
helpful right help me to prepare for
something but when it gets to the aspect
of sort of clinically significant it's
interfering in such a way that now I
just called out of my job interview or
I'm choosing not to go or I I I couldn't
I couldn't even bring myself to study
because I was so anxious about the
potential exam and so it becomes almost
um
self-sabotaging in some ways as as we
move towards like a clinically
significant version of that so what is
treatment like for someone that's in
that zone I haven't been out of my house
I didn't get the job I didn't do go to
the job interview I actually haven't
even applied for any jobs I'm you know
could just getting by on whatever
savings I had and maybe start to get
some welfare checks because I'm just
freaked out because so what are you
saying to me how do we talk someone
through that
well I mean a lot of it has to do with
um well I know we were talking about
this before recording that when somebody
is that kind of agitated and in distress
the front part of your brain the
prefrontal cortex which is the part we
use for like weighing pros and cons and
anticipating outcomes and
um kind of making decisions and thinking
things through is almost like not
available it's almost offline you can
think about it like it got knocked
offline because my nervous system is a
wreck so the person really
can't make really good decisions when
they're that
um kind of escalated so treatment will
like undoubtedly no matter what include
helping a person learn skills and
techniques to like calm their like
literally calm their physical body down
it doesn't I always tell people you
don't have to be calm that would be
lovely but you don't have to be calm you
just have to be calm enough for your
brain what are some techniques you're
going to teach somebody
it could be like a deep breathing
techniques meditation grounding physical
activity is really really helpful for a
dysregulated body like walking running
jumping you to swimming yoga whatever
physical activity because it's a it's a
physical manifestation of the anxiety so
you got to get the body to be able to
relax enough
for the brain to come online so now once
the brain is more available now we got
to go through all that cogn that
cognitive distortion this idea that like
if you don't get this job you're a
horrible person like let's let's talk
about how realistic that is or if you
don't get this job it means that you're
never going to get a job for the rest of
your life well let's look at that so
cognitive like cognitive behavioral
therapy cognitive techniques will
address
some of those
really kind of extreme escalated
thoughts so you need both I mean most
mental health and illness issues are
going to require both but for anxiety
you really need both the physical and
the cognitive
as I was reading through this I ended up
with these personality disorders coming
into these different categories cluster
a cluster B and cluster C cluster a is
just they had some subtitles here
cluster a was odd yep odd cluster B was
dramatic and cluster C was anxious and I
was like well you could kind of like the
stereotypical
categories of people you know that guy's
weird right that guy's a hot guy
um someone that's paranoid paranoid is
one of the things in cluster a odd
paranoid always on guard believe people
are trying to harm them
um schizoid which I didn't really know
the definition of schizoid is people
that avoid people and relationships so
tell me about paranoid well look give me
a case let me let me redefine that let
me hear a case I want to hear some case
studies of paranoid hey
um you know the black helicopters are
out there flying around yeah well you
know what you said earlier actually
about like a person who might already be
a little bit say maybe predisposed to
like conspiracy right so with
personality disorders it's it's not
it's more like a part of your like I can
be a shy person and which means I'm
probably going to be shy like across the
board right not just in one or two
situations so with personality disorders
it's one of those like kind of in most
situations you're gonna see so paranoid
it might be not the the helicopters are
chasing me that that's probably you're
more in the um psychotic psychosis realm
there personality disorders might be
just kind of a general paranoia like
well you know every time I go to work I
say hi to the girl at the desk and she
says and say hi to me I think she
doesn't like me she probably XYZ like a
like a a leaning or a disposition to
thinking if people don't like me I think
people are watching me I think somebody
went into my locker and took something
out I think
you know I found it at home later that
night but like my predisposition is
paranoid versus
psychosis which is going to be the
helicopters are chasing me the lights
are secretly you know filming me the you
know I mentioned that thing earlier
where I said I told people on my uh
training course like Hey we're all
insane we're all some level of insane
because reality was different these
things are the same too like everyone's
got some level of paranoia and you can
see it come out of people you know got
that person here I work with leaders a
lot and you know a leader that might be
like well I'm never going to get
promoted oh why is that oh they don't
like me like it's just a level of
paranoia that's and it's usually because
while I'm actually not getting promoted
because you failed on your last two
projects has nothing to them do with
them not liking you you you're not
performing well but of course for them
it's they don't like me why don't they
like you well because I used to work at
this other company and that guy worked
there and they don't like that guy and
so therefore they don't like me so like
all these things and anxiety you know
right we we talk about you you just
mentioned Megan's like a certain level
of anxiety is good so it's okay hey I'm
nervous about this job interview because
I really want to get the job strong
therefore I'm going to research the
company to be prepared well I'm going to
go over some notes I'm going to be ready
that's cool that's great so everyone has
some level of these things going on it's
just when we start to let them spiral
and get out of control that's when we
have problems
um
so cluster a we're acting a little
strange cluster be dramatic
which is this also known as teenage
years a little bit
oftentimes with some of that you'll find
you know some form of an attachment
disruption or something happening during
that time period that leads to some of
this in more adult life where we're
looking at like a pattern of unstable
relationships or sort of this real or
imagined fear of Abandonment that leads
me to sort of be dramatic if that's what
you the word you want to use in
relationships and such in response to a
perception that I might be losing you a
lot of push-pull these sorts of things
but I think we can find often in this
group that there's some something that
happened in the attachment that led to
this disposition for what kind of thing
is happening I mean it can be a wide
variety of things it can be various
levels of abuse sexual abuse physical
abuse could be a very misattuned parent
or maybe not having somebody who could
reflect back to you at a young age
marrying sort of like um you know I feel
uh sad or I feel afraid it's sort of
normal to feel that way instead of like
don't feel that way or there's something
wrong with you for feeling that way and
I start to build these beliefs where I
sort of lose touch with my map for like
an appropriate emotional response to
what's happening you can kind of find
that disruption and sometimes with when
you're looking at a personality disorder
something has been so severe that now it
is part of the personality in some ways
and so you can shape it and kind of lose
some things with the volume of it but
that disposition might always be there
to be sort of like
um you know someone my friend canceled
you know dinner on me again they must
really not like me or must not be
important to them as opposed to like
maybe there's something else going on
for them as to why they cancel dinner
um but it really does feel that
traumatic to the person and I think
that's a really important part of
working with someone with a personality
disorder is is recognizing that while it
might look sort of irrational and you're
like what's going on for them it feels
very real so this piece of like how do I
calm down the body enough to bring the
brain online to be able to just consider
what else might be possible is a super
important part of helping somebody
through that and you can see with time
with like an appropriate level support
and period of time and multiple
reparative experiences and relationships
where the thing that I fear didn't
actually happen that that some of this
can calm down a little bit you'll see
especially in what's considered cluster
B
[Music]
um
people who have been adopted given up
for adoption early on or or in a way
that was left them for some period of
time without kind of a secure like a
parent or authority attachment
um
clients who
uh like I have one client who is she's
the the definition of that was neglected
like severe andly neglected when she was
a child so this anxiety of like being
left or not being wanted or being
um
some like picking somebody other than
her like this felt sense of rejection is
so profound it almost it's like a lenses
it just it's like her and her experience
in the world with other people is always
through this lens of like do you like me
are you gonna pick me
um like am I am I safe can I rely on you
can I trust you so these are they can be
rough is this uh one of these things was
called histrionic histrionic personality
disorder which in one of the categories
in there was desire to be noticed this
is a similar thing where I just want
people to see that I'm here well and you
know what I would say and I say this a
lot clinically too is this idea that
like um oh the person she's like seeking
attention she's attention seeking that's
very common right term that's used and
um but often used in like a um
judgmental judgmental derogatory way I
would say like oh they're absolutely
seeking attention but not because
they're just being like
you know irritating it's something is
going on for this person internally that
they like literally need you to stop and
like pay attention to me so I can
something inside of me settles down now
this is a huge dysregulation right so
this is where
um in terms of therapy and treatment
comes in is helping people learn how to
regulate their body and like calm some
of that agitation down and then do all
the cognitive work of helping like
reality check like right kind of sort
through some of these big extreme
thoughts that I have to be like are they
really that realistic and then like you
have said a couple times Megan the
reparative experiences like
um you know how many times did you think
like I have a client who for the longest
time she would show up like 15 20
minutes early to her session
because she had this idea that what if
she's not out there at the time of our
session and I forget we had a session
and I leave which first of all would
never ever happen in a million years
ever but like this was the one who grew
up with a lot of neglect grew up with
parents saying oh yeah I'll be home I'll
be home in a few hours and they didn't
come home or they forgot about her right
so you can see where like the early
stuff shaped this but a lot of our work
was it wasn't just like saying hey
we've had 72 sessions and I've been here
every time like isn't that enough that
wasn't not enough for her like she
needed to really go through the
experience of not relying on me to be
there on time so that she felt better
she had to learn how to do that for
herself it's that external scaffolding
versus the internal and was she able to
yeah totally she's I still see her she's
great you still see her but she but it's
more like just checking in yeah and it's
more like maintenance I see her once or
twice a month I used to see her two
three times a week because because the
level of distress and interference in
her life like she couldn't work her
relationships were a mess she was on all
these medication I mean she had a really
really messy life because this is how
she lived it this is how she approached
almost every relationship she had in her
world so now like she's working she's
got kids she's got back from like
Bali or something I don't know she went
with her husband like her life is great
so things are good it so it's a little
maintenance what kind of Maintenance car
maintenance
every once in a while yeah it's weird
because all these things are P everyone
listening can be like oh yeah I I have a
little bit of that I have a little bit
of that I have a little bit of this well
another one in this category was
narcissistic
which you know when when we work with
leaders you know a lot of times people
that end up in leadership positions they
end up in leadership positions
oftentimes because they were stepping up
and they thought they could do the job
and if you can think you can do the job
that means you got a little bit of ego
working and if you got a little bit ego
working sometimes that ego can start to
expand beyond your own control and you
end up sometimes with people that are
narcissistic and
what does that look like from like a
clinical perspective
I mean I think when you you talk about
this from like a clinical where you're
ending up in treatment it it moves into
a place where you have um you lose sight
of uh I don't know if empathy is the
right word or like my impact on other
people like my focus becomes so much on
like where I'm at my my vision whatever
I have going on and and somehow along
the way I lost sight of like what I do
uh impacts other people and like my
behavior has an impact on other people
and so that's on the very severe end and
I think when you're looking at the
actual disorder itself that word is
thrown around a lot for sure
um but where we've seen it often really
looks like this person uh has become
significantly self-focused
um and really lose sight of how their
behavior impacts other people and they
just don't care about anybody else it
would appear that way I mean I think on
what's really happening so much is that
there's the the ego cannot tolerate any
sort of feedback that would suggest like
wow I might have hurt someone when I did
that like it's just so vulnerable like
it's actually this person while they
might appear like it doesn't matter to
them they're actually so sensitive and
vulnerable that they've been built up so
many defenses in their psyche to not
allow for any sort of feedback to crack
through an idea of like oh in fact I
could potentially fail or in fact like I
could I do have the potential to hurt
someone it's like um become so distorted
in a way that they they can't even see
that as a possibility and so then I come
across in my behaviors and such as very
disregarding of others these uh a person
with a narcissist personality is very
easily wounded with your words they're
not the person that you can give that
sort of direct feedback to they're so
wounded almost catastrophic to the
relationship sometimes to be able to
give feedback and what you will see uh
as opposed to some of the other
personality just sort like the
histrionic borderline and they're
easily easily wounded with words very
very sensitive but you're going to see
somebody kind of melt down and cry and
oh my gosh I can't believe you said that
to me you know like like kind of
collapse a little bit with narcissism
lash out and like cut you off out gone
yeah I can just cannot tolerate like
kind of being challenged
cluster C which is which is anxious this
is when you get in the OCD the the
obsessive compulsive let me hear a wild
OCD story
let's see I don't know if I have a good
one to go
well I I mean several and I think
like we said before there's people can
have like kind of traits and like
leanings and inclinations and that's one
thing versus it being at a
like a clinic clinically significant
level where like your life like you're
having a hard time living your life so
somebody who's a little bit more
um extreme might be like OCD might be
say a germs right so they don't I don't
want to touch doorknobs shake hands use
public restrooms
during covet
they loved it a lot of people because
they're just like so much Social
distancing I don't have to touch anybody
and you have to wear a mask in front of
me sure yes they were stoked
those are the ones that are gonna have a
lot harder time
socially engaging
um taking risks right like the idea of
like
well the only restroom here is a public
room and you gotta go in there or hold
it like you know that that's going to be
very distressing for somebody that leans
a little bit more towards um obsessive
obsessions and compulsions yeah well
what did covid look like because I've
done a couple podcasts about deaths of
Despair during covet it's a nightmare
um from your professional perspective
how bad was it oh my gosh I mean it was
it was significant because I mean
already especially when you're working
with very complex psychiatric disorders
resources and like access to hospitals
and such as is always sort of an issue
for our folks because you know there is
certain criteria related to being able
to get Hospital support somebody has to
be very sort of significantly regressed
to be able to get Hospital support if
they need that and there oftentimes
isn't that level of care that allows for
that like sort of least restrictive
setting in order to be able to support
them
um outside of the hospital I mean that
in order for me to go and get help I
needed to be in really bad shape which
means I'm in really bad shape well
that's in general for folks with mental
awesomenas you need to be a danger to
yourself or others and meet criteria
like significantly be a danger to
yourself or others to be able to get
that you know kind of inpatient
hospitalization unless you're willing to
go on your own which oftentimes when
someone is in that state they they might
not be so then with covet obviously
access to resources and beds became
significantly less that you have a
significant more isolation which is a
huge risk factor for our folks isolation
undoubtedly will increase you know
symptoms of psychosis depression anxiety
because you know when I go inside my
head and I have this internal side of
ISO relation a lot can happen and so
just being in contact with other people
making eye contact with you these things
they're like grounding to the person so
all of that is impacted and then how we
had to do therapy shifted significantly
I mean we moved from a residential
setting where we're seeing people in
person we're going to outings together
we're meeting in groups together to like
now I'm doing uh over the computer with
you with somebody who may have some
significant psychosis around computer
use so they're not even going to get on
the camera with you so it just really
impacted our ability to provide care
during that time and people responded I
think you know I can't speak for all
settings but you know as best as they
could during that time to be able to
provide services and such and maintain
the level of services that people needed
um it was a definitely a really
difficult time and you know Telehealth
is a super great option it's not the
best option for every client you know
that in person
um
is so important and a lot of times for
our folks because a lot of talk therapy
is very cognitive and if you're working
with someone with a cognitive disorder
or a thought disorder you know
oftentimes your sessions look like going
for a walk or baking a pie together or
like something of that nature that
really like we couldn't do so much
during that time or if we did it was you
know an increased risk to the person in
their health especially during the time
of covet where we didn't really know too
much about right what was happening and
all these regulations came in and like
you had to have all this distance and
couldn't do these things um
it uh it impact it impacted a lot
and I think um also seeing especially
for people who are
seemed like in that age range like maybe
Middle School going into high school
like right somewhere in there where a
lot of social things are happening like
your life is kind of socially driven
your friends access to your friends what
everybody else is doing you're growing
up maybe starting to think about college
things like that where there was this
instant you know kind of a halt and
people were not going to school and
having to do their classes online and
not seeing their friends so I saw a lot
especially in the younger population
almost um
like an Arrested Development of Social
Development so now like yeah my clients
who are 20 21 22 but you're talking to
them and you're like wow you really
sound like 16 or 17 years old right now
like they kind of stalled out in the
natural progression I mean my my niece
and my nephew um one was graduating
college and one was graduating high
school right when covet happened so like
that may or whatever so like
you know graduations no
you know the Pomp and Circumstance that
comes with these milestones and and
Rites of Passage in life they didn't
have those
um
they seem to fare okay but I think about
all the folks that like well what did
that mean for their lives or
um the sense of missing out on something
important and not having had the same
opportunities and
I saw a lot of anxiety a lot of anxiety
depression and isolation fear so much
fear actually I was on a podcast a
couple weeks ago where we were talking
about
um
how people like remember when we were
able like going to the grocery store
like you know everyone's like head down
and you're like not looking at anybody
and don't get too close like it was very
like weird and this like that stayed
like the people weren't like oh hey
how's it going nice to see you haven't
seen you in a couple months and give you
a house I was like that for about three
days yeah I'm going to the store yeah
but it is still like that I mean some of
that is still happening so the fear so
when again going back to that nervous
system thing right so if People's fear
is up here and I'm constantly on alert
and watching and waiting and who's
wearing their mask and who isn't when
you're not on the dot in the grocery
store like people are not using their
brains like they're not using these the
part of the brain that could be like
okay it's chill it's cool we're fine
we're good because you're you're keyed
up all the time I think that is still
happening sure we have not seen the end
of the effect of that well and those who
had a propensity towards anxiety prior
were struggling through some of that I
mean significant more damage and then
you you saw it happen when there was the
decision of could we take the masks on
or off and those who chose to keep it on
and those who didn't you know it was
very interesting when you would listen
to folks perspective on that but
oftentimes it felt especially for some
of the younger kids like protective to
have that over the face in some ways
um
very interesting impact
man that's um that's crazy uh what about
addiction and it's funny because like
you can get addicted to anything
apparently right like people get
addicted to anything but alcohol opioids
cocaine amphetamines hallucinogens
um
PCP cat like people
it's crazy anything and everything tick
tock tick tock
uh let's jump to um PTSD so you know
obviously in the veteran Community PTSD
has been a huge uh news story and it's
had a really big impact on
you know on a lot of people
um
sometimes I think well some people could
actually use that kick in the ass that I
talked about earlier like hey dude yeah
you saw some bad stuff you awesome
friends but it's time to move on
um and I think some some people need
that sort of Direction
I mean look we've been going to Wars
since the beginning of mankind I mean
and
you know you look at the other Wars that
we've been through in America World War
One World War II Korea Vietnam these
were incredibly horrific Wars as all
wars are
um
when when
you guys look at PTSD what do you think
um from a from like a National
perspective of where it's at how it's
being handled do you think it's being
handled the right way what could we do
better
I mean you're out there freaking with a
in a in a foxhole with a pistol and a
scorpion
I should write a book that's the book
title right there
I mean I mean I've def I'm not a public
health expert I don't have the national
kind of response to some of this I mean
what I'll what I'll say in my private
practice specifically to Veterans is
that
um whether sort of real or imagine the
military Armed Forces in general is
doing a lot to try to address providing
resources early intervention
um what traumatic events occur having
people on site who are trained to be
able to help support I mean there's a
lot that's happening but stigma the
notion of stigma is is still very
present with regard to what it means to
have mental health issues and so I often
have both active duty and Veterans find
me in my private practice knowing that I
um uh was previous military I think they
feel a draw to me in that way in that
history that I'm a safe person coming to
me because it doesn't in that
environment feel safe just yet to be
able to talk openly about what's going
on for me
um because of I mean I think there's two
really primary themes which look like
privacy like will what I have to share
stay private to me or if I talk about
this will my medical officer then know
and now my CEO knows and now if
somebody's having a talk with me about
something I shared or this notion of
retaliation in some ways because
somebody heard a story from somebody
that they told someone they had
depression they were put on
antidepressant now they took my wings
which is like my whole identity so
whether these things are actually
happening it's still very much so part
of the culture or suggestion of like is
it safe to to like talk about these
things and so
I think from that perspective in terms
of what we can do is it's it's amazing
all of the resources that are being
created and opportunities I just
recently read about like it's referred
to as the Sprint team but it's essential
it's a special psychiatric unit as part
of the the Armed Forces where they come
on site in response to like a trauma or
something that's very awesome but
engagement in the resources still a
really important factor especially for
veterans who disengage from like use of
VHA services or anything like that so
like getting people to engage and like I
you know what we know about engagement
in general is that like that initial
response to someone's willingness and we
talked about this earlier to disclose or
talk about what's going on for them
um it's critical because it's going to
shape whether or not they feel they can
do that
um and so I think engagement is huge
both in the active duty and Veteran
realm and what we see with a lot of
veterans and why they usually end up
finding me in private practice not part
of their insurance or anything like that
is the Privacy Factor but also um you
know when you're separating from the
military part of your access to
resources and disability and these sorts
of things is directly connected to your
service record what was disclosed while
you were in the military and so if I'm
in a culture real or imagined or in my
mind I feel like this is not a place
where I can talk about these things so
I've chosen not to I've sort of
white-knuckled it I've gotten through I
haven't shared a whole lot here I am as
a veteran looking towards trying to get
some services or disability or maybe now
I'm realizing I'm no longer in the
structure of that military environment
and so all this stuff is coming up for
me that may be the structure of that
environment sort of kept at Bay and I'm
being told well there's there's nothing
here to suggest in your record that
anything significant happened to you so
you have to kind of convince me in some
ways as to why you should get this
disability percentage or why you should
be treated for these and the way it's
looked at is based on you know PTSD or
everything is broken down in Parts your
back is one part your PTSD your mental
health is one part your your arm is one
part of that and they're all looked at
differently in that way and so it puts a
veteran in a position where they have to
sort of now prove in some ways that they
are deserving of this disability can be
very re-traumatizing for someone who's
maybe never shared about something that
happened in the sexual assault or
something that happened to me while I
was deployed or something that's sort of
embarrassing or I hold a lot of Shame
about because I haven't really dealt
with now I'm in this position where I
have to sort of recount all this I have
to get these um character references for
these things that happen to sort of
prove that I'm worthy of this disability
which then opens me up to these like
resources in some ways and so that part
um you know what we can do sort of like
as a leader in an initial response to
somebody you know a sailor coming to
tell us something that's going on um how
we react and that moment is huge because
it's going to set the precedent for
whether or not that person is going to
re-engage should something be going on
for them or if it's a safe place to talk
about the things that are going on so I
mean to answer your question long way
around I don't know about nationally
like what we're doing if it's the right
thing to do but I do know like
engagement and all the resources that
are being put out there is still an
issue and I I read something from the
the Navy like it was like a 2021 study
around veteran suicide rates and all
these different things and the suicide
rate daily for those individuals who
were engaged with the VHA was less than
those who were not right so
um engagement uh is a really important
factor in how do we keep people doing
that well I think making sure that we
understand how important privacy is to
someone who's dealing with something
like this
um and um what the fear of retaliation
like will you take something that's
important to me will you take my wings
like will you you know that you know
these are people's full identity you
know will I lose my will I lose my my
status by spot as part of this group
that I've been so connected to I see
this a lot in folks coming through and
um
you know Special Operations or things
like that like they're more likely to
seek services in my experience outside
of the military out of fear of those two
things yeah
I got
being aware of what's going on in the
world is such an advantage and my basic
example of that is if if you came to my
house and I said hey
I'm gonna scare you when you walk down
the hallway and then you walk down the
hallway and I jumped out and said boo
you wouldn't be scared at all if you if
I didn't tell you that and you came
walking down my house and I jumped out
of you know out of the doorway and
screamed at you you'd be scared because
that's what would happen so being aware
of what's going on just makes you so
much more prepared for it so I realized
um and working with Fighters and being
in combat
you'd see like a new guy that was on his
first deployment and you'd see him
before an operation and you'd see he's
really nervous
and you know maybe feels like a little
bit sick to his stomach he's gone to the
bathroom four times in the last 20
minutes and you're like oh yeah he's got
a little bit of that a little bit of
those nerves going and you say something
to him like Hey man
yeah that's the fourth time you go to
the bathroom are you all right they're
like I'm fine and you're like hey dude
it's fine like you're nervous you might
get killed it's no big deal to be a
little bit nervous and I go okay
okay it's okay it's okay that you're
nervous you should be nervous if you're
not nervous there's something wrong with
you and then so I took that and I had
actually used it when I was training
mixed martial arts Fighters because they
the same thing would happen they'd
they'd be going you know the night of
the UFC or a few hours before they're
all nervous you could see that they're
nervous
but they don't know what it is they
don't know why they feel sick so they
think there's something wrong with them
so now they're now now they're freaking
out so you go oh you're hey you just
went to the bathroom for the ninth time
in the last half an hour you feel a
little nervous and they go uh no I don't
know what's wrong with me hey what's
wrong with you is you're getting ready
to go into combat you're getting ready
to take some chances and that's your
body getting ready getting rid of all
the stuff it doesn't need right now so
we can focus on fighting this is good
and they think oh okay so that's what
normal is it's okay to feel like that I
had a guy on my on my podcast named Tom
Fife who was in World War II Korea and
Vietnam and he got a Purple Heart in
World War II Korea in Vietnam
and I was asking him he was a battalion
commander in Vietnam and uh and so this
was you know had been 55 or 60 years
since he was in Vietnam
and I was asking him about you know what
type of operations they were doing and I
started asking him about what kind of
casualties he took
in his battalion
and as he started to address that
he started getting choked up talking
about it
and I remember I'm sitting there
thinking it's been 60 years for this guy
and he was a battalion commander and he
lost guys and he still gets choked up
about it and because that that'll happen
to me I'll be talking to someone about
some of the guys that I lost and I'll
get choked up and I said to myself oh
this is just the way it is and it's
normal and it's okay
and I think that's a huge part that we
missed out on and that we have missed
out on is someone going oh
I'm sad
there must be something wrong with me
and it's like no you're sad you lost
your friend and you lost your friend and
now you feel sad and that's what's
that's what you're going to feel like
and over time it'll dissipate a little
bit and then it might come back you know
that's another uh
thing that I talked about I talked about
losing people and what you go through
and what what and I went through this
big dramatic
um description of being caught in a
storm and when you lose someone when
someone when one of your friends dies
you're gonna be hit with emotions that
you can't control and we as adults we're
not used to not being able to control
our emotions anymore that happens when
you're when you're five years old it
shouldn't happening when I'm 40. so my
friend dies all of a sudden I get hit
with these emotions I'm not in control
anymore and I don't like that feeling
and I think there must be something
wrong with me it's like no actually this
is what's normal you're getting hit with
these emotions but guess what eventually
those wave those waves of emotions
will go away and you'll have a break
okay so then you think okay well then
I'm fine but then you get hit randomly
you see something you hear a song you
smell something you drive by whatever
restaurant and you get hit with that
emotion again
you don't notice this but it's not quite
as strong
and there's been a little space and over
time the the strength of the emotional
waves starts to lessen and this is what
I've I've learned this for myself
because I experienced it a bunch of
times
and by the sixth or seventh or eighth
time I was saying oh yeah this is that
emotion that I'm gonna feel right now
and I don't can't control it and I'm
gonna sit here and cry and then I'm
gonna stop and then 20 minutes later I'm
gonna be laughing and that'll seem I
don't seem like I'm okay but then a week
later I'll get hit with this other
emotion again this sadness and it'll
knock me knock me down
but it's gonna lessen over time and it's
going to dissipate
so I think a lot of this is people don't
people don't understand what's normal
and I think that everything I just said
is totally normal and now that I've told
that to a bunch of people yeah this is
what you're gonna feel they've been like
that's exactly what I felt and and so
getting the word out about yeah oh yeah
you're gonna feel sad this doesn't mean
you're depressed it means you're sad
your friend died like that's a horrible
thing
but it's okay to feel sad and it's okay
in a little while
it'll dissipate that's another thing
people get caught up in is oh the strong
emotions that I had are now dissipating
I must be I didn't really care about her
[__] I'm I'm a bad person because no
you're just processing it and you're
moving through this thing so
I think a lot of just the you know what
you were talking about earlier Carlin
have just
not talking about things and I've been
very lucky and this is another thing I
noticed about loss is when I would lose
one of my friends oftentimes I would be
the person that would be giving a speech
or one of the people that would be
writing down
my feelings about the situation about
who this person was about what they
meant to me about how awesome they were
I'd I'd have to go through that drill
mandatory because you're going to get up
and you're going to talk you're going to
give a eulogy or one of the eulogies
that someone's funeral someone's
memorial service so that's what you're
doing what a cathartic thing that turned
out to be then I end up when I get out
of the Navy I end up writing books and
oftentimes these things are addressed in
the books
and being on this podcast or going out
speaking groups people guess what I'm
doing I'm telling a story over and over
again
the same story about the same situation
and each time you tell it
you go okay you process it and it moves
you further down that road and it helps
you detach from it not in a bad way but
in a good way where you can be truly
appreciative of the friend that you lost
and say yeah it's horrible but guess
what I had some good times we had some
great times we had some incredible times
and I'm gonna live a good life and not
forget about them but I'm not going to
dwell on the fact that they died and by
the way guess what that means that means
I'm gonna die too
and everyone I know is gonna die and I I
can't get caught up and dwell on that
fact for so long so it seems like those
are the kind of things that I think we
could do better is letting people
understand what they're going through
letting them understand that it's normal
it's normal it's normal to be like oh
yeah oh what's wrong with Jaco he just
heard a song and he's gonna go over
there and cry for like eight minutes and
just then he's gonna be okay and and
Jocko's not embarrassed by it it's like
oh yeah this song freaking bums me out
sometimes okay well that's not abnormal
you lost one of your best friends okay
well it's gonna be sad sometimes and I
think that's one thing that we can do
better not try and do that as much as I
can when we talk about these things on
this podcast
um but it also sounds like that's the
kind of thing that you all would do with
people as you talk them through
issues that they've gone through in your
life am I accurate absolutely well and
to speak to the example you gave with um
the gentleman you noticed he was going
to the bathroom I mean you also saw him
like you you saw him you saw he was
struggling through something you choose
chose to engage you chose to interact
and I think that that you know not just
from the encouragement or the cognitive
part of the conversation but to see
people to notice them is huge because
you know that could have gone completely
unnoticed and in his mind he could have
created a whole different narrative
about everybody else seems to be fine
and they're doing okay and they've got a
bunch of skills they're all acting like
they're fine
and I I'm Different in some ways you
know so to like to see that person to
make that eye contact that's the scary
thing like I must be a coward absolutely
why is everyone walking around like a
badass right and I'm sitting here like a
coward yep and in the absence of the
communication or in the Attunement that
you gave him like all kinds of things
can happen so that's huge
yeah and I think with um especially in
the treatment world and at Anew for sure
um a lot of our clients come in the ones
who have been in the system for a bit
this is like not their first rodeo there
is that identity that has almost been
adopted a lot of the times like I I'm
schizophrenic
so I need to take these pills yeah I'm
cursed I need to take these pills why
are you taking them I don't know it's
just what they give me right there's
this kind of
um when will my symptoms go away right
this this lack of what you're talking
about is like it's totally normal that
that's happening today I get yesterday
you felt great and today you woke up
thinking these things that you weren't
thinking yesterday
yes we're gonna move and March toward
what can we do about it what we can we
do to help you feel better sometimes
it's just going and having your cry over
there and then come back on over totally
fine but the idea of validating is what
like you're talking about it's like yep
that's happening I get it and it sucks
today and it may even suck tomorrow you
have schizophrenia this might be
something that you deal with on and off
your entire life but by doing these
things having it normalized people being
seen people supporting versus
why are you doing that yeah
um over time it gets less and less yeah
that's what I was going to say but the
little kid that asked me like I feel I
feel like I'm alone yeah yeah you're
gonna feel alone that's totally normal
sometimes you're gonna be alone like
that's gonna happen and when you're a
teenager and you don't get invited to
the party
you're gonna be bummed out that's just
normal that's just like oh and when
you're a teenager and your boyfriend or
your girlfriend dumps you
yeah you're gonna feel sad and that's
just the way you feel and in a little
while you won't even remember that
person was and you'll carry on with the
rest of your life so being aware of
what's going on and these these uh Peaks
and valleys of life knowing that they're
there
it is such a positive thing and a lot of
times and I I guess especially going
back to social media was like oh if all
I see on social media is everyone's
smiling and happy and looks you know
like they're doing some awesome thing
and I'm sitting at home in my room alone
but that's life you're gonna be alone
you're gonna get dumped you're not gonna
get invited to the cool cool guy party
all these things are happening they're
totally normal and you'll get through
them and they're not going to be fun but
that's the way it is
we get we get a lot of uh
people that don't even recognize that
this is the way life is well actually
um we were just talking the other day
you know I I
um my friend Jordan Peterson will say
life is suffering right and it's like a
religious context the Buddhist says life
is suffering and I was like yeah you
know
I get it that's a good way it's a good
thing to know it's a good thing to know
that that life that in life there is
suffering right but you don't have to go
and say life all of life is suffering
there's going to be some valleys you
know there's gonna be some Darkness we
get it but it's not all of life and
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
come out of that you're gonna see some
light you're gonna have some fun and
you're gonna but then you're gonna get
suck down into some Darkness again and
and that's that's what I think people
don't or what I think people need to
understand is there's a cycle to life
and you're gonna have some good and
you're gonna have some bad and that's
the same with everybody no one is just
basking in the in the in the sun and the
warmth for their whole life unless
you're only looking at them on Instagram
in which case they're doing it and
they're doing it in a G-string bikini
yeah that's the way they're doing it
yeah that's true and and with PTSD a lot
of other things too a lot of other
um conditions or diagnosis I mean I've
heard this so many times we definitely
hear it at the treatment center for
people who've been maybe in an illness
for a lot longer so when is this going
to go away when am I going to not have
this anymore and this idea of like it it
may not kind of like with trauma right
every time you remember that buddy or
hear that song you're gonna have a
little something show up and yeah is it
that's less than before sure but like
maybe your whole life every time you
hear that song you might feel a little
something going on there and that's okay
like that gets told totally normal I
feel that when I hear the Star-Spangled
Banner like when I hear the
Star-Spangled Banner if I'm not careful
I'll get like super emotional yeah from
the start and that's a song that you
hear a lot right all the time I mean
you're at every sporting event so yeah
and here's the thing I guess in my own
narcissistic mind I thought hey that's
normal and I'm that's okay it's okay
it's okay to feel like that yeah this is
the way things go where you know you
mentioned um quickly there you mentioned
drugs and I just had a a friend of mine
on the podcast who
by the time he went and saw sought help
in the navy hues and the SEAL Teams by
the time he went and sought help he got
immediately prescribed something by the
time he got out a year or two later he
was on seven
seven different
um drugs
you know this one to get you to get you
amped up for the day
this one to keep you level-headed this
one to put you to sleep at night is like
they're all counter to each other
and just just a disaster
at what point where where did these
drugs come into play now we he and I
both acknowledged and again this is
something that that I know from from
talking and reading is absolutely
there's times like oh this person needs
this specific drug to help them get
through this situation
where do you where do you all think
these drugs come into play and what do
we need to be careful of
yeah I mean I
I'm not a psychiatrist so it's hard to
speak to that part but generally when
somebody's coming in on a bunch of
different medications you know there's a
there's a conversation about like do you
do you know what you're taking
oftentimes with folks with complex
psychiatric disorders they they don't
it's just this is what I was told to
take you know what it's treating how do
you know that it's helping you and
really starting to discern that because
I mean I think we
you know and this my opinion in some
ways but in a culture of sort of instant
gratification or seeking something
outside of myself to soothe you know
there there's a lot of benefit to
various you know psychiatric medications
they can really help stabilize someone
in a place where without otherwise they
might not be able to receive some of
that treatment
um and at some point assessing like why
I use this I think is really important
right do I use it because I think it's
going to fix or take this thing away I
think this would apply to not just a
prescription drug but any kind of
substance you know why do I drink do I
do because I enjoy a glass of wine at
night or whatever may be or do I drink
to alter my mood do I change this to
alter my mood in a way because I don't
feel like I can do this independently or
on my own so I think assessing why
someone is using the various amount of
things and their understanding of it and
um you know one of the things the
benefits of being able to do long-term
treatment in a structured environment is
it gives us an opportunity to sort of
unpack some of these things obviously
with the support of a psychiatrist and
somebody you know who's medical
overseeing their care to see the um
you know what what in fact is this
actually treating at this point is it
helpful and if it is great but also too
does it take us out of the role of like
the work because you know therapy is
hard work like people I think there is a
soft place to come and whatever therapy
is hard work someone who commits to
therapy is really willing to do some
work I mean unless you're in a place
where somebody's just like buttering you
up and giving you compliments all day
long but when you come to do therapy you
come to do work especially in a
residential treatment center you're not
just receiving all these things but
medications often is this notion of like
I'm just taking this thing there's no um
it's very different than the um the
amount of effort that's involved in
walking through a very difficult
situation or if I'm afraid of something
in particular I haven't gone to address
some of this unresolved grief or you
know whatever may be you know engaging
in that behavior it's very difficult
it's going to bring up a lot of feelings
um and and walking through that can be
incredibly healing a very different
approach than if I'm choosing to just
take something to get rid of something I
think there's like an agency thing which
I think shows up in a lot of your work I
mean even just what you've shared today
is people say like oh I I I'm I'm
feeling so much I'm going to call my
psychiatrist I'm gonna call the doctor I
need to I need something for this is
very external one instant gratification
but also this
whether the person's aware of it or not
this idea that like I don't believe in
my ability to manage myself I need you
to give me something to feel better and
a lot of the longer term work in therapy
definitely in our program because it's
so it's longer term is this idea of
helping people internalize agency versus
just rely on external things to like
make them be okay
yeah that seems like a basic principle
of success in life but you'd be amazed
with people with some of these complex
psychiatric diagnoses that that's the
the sense of personal agency is so low
whether it's like I just take these
pills because my psychiatrist says I'm
supposed to or my mom says I need to
versus like do you know what what are
you taking
um or having conversation with your
doctor about
side effects or whatever but this sense
of I don't have I don't have what it
takes to manage myself and my situation
and the demands of life so it's a
horrible mindset horrible and it's very
very common with mental illness yeah
I mentioned I talked about ssris on some
other podcast and and uh you know I read
through the comments and you know there
was definitely some people that were
like hey you know these things really
helped me and there's and of course
you're going to get that side and you of
course got the side of like oh that that
stuff was a disaster for me
um but the side effects when you when
you read the side effects you're like oh
my God you know like emotional blunting
violence bipolar switch suicide risk
from the medicine that you're taking so
there's definite risks need to that
needs to be paid attention to
um
the other side of the spectrum as far as
I'm concerned
is something that you are you already
mentioned Carlin uh what about just like
a sleep diet and exercise how often are
we how often are we blowing that often
often often I mean it is amazing when
when we bring folks into the the program
we try and set aside like kind of the
first month give or take it may take
longer because this person maybe has not
been sleeping well at all
um not eating well like maybe they've
been using maybe they haven't poor
hygiene had caffeine smoking I mean you
name it so just like getting somebody
eating well and on a regular basis
getting some physical exercise getting
like their sleep hygiene in order uh
structuring some habits throughout the
day you're gonna be amazed how much
change is just in that little period of
time and we've talked with folks that
and this is also related to the meds
sometimes when people have they're
seeing multiple doctors or they go in
and they see a different doctor every
time
and who and they may not be coordinating
so you're just getting all kinds of meds
and things that may not even really go
together so same with diagnoses we've
had folks come in with a laundry list of
diagnoses where I'm like you can't even
have half of those at the same time at
the same time like but these were all
little snapshots of oh this trip to the
ER and this trip to the hospital like
this is what they look like that day and
that's what they look like this day it
doesn't mean they have all of those
things so let's get them eating and
sleeping and in a routine and
comfortable showering physical activity
it's the basic psychological and
physical wellness and safety and guess
what almost all of these diagnoses go
away maybe we're left with like these
couple right here yeah I was on uh I was
on Joe Rogan's podcast and it was it was
the morning of Chris Cornell from from
Soundgarden had killed himself and of
course you know
um Joe and I started talking about it
and look we're just a couple knuckle
draggers talking
um but you know both of us were kind of
like man you know like get a kettlebell
to work out like and you know again like
I said we're just a couple knuckle
draggers talking and you know again
reading the comments
um people like oh you know you think
just working out's gonna solve
everything and of course I don't think
that but damn
it's a good thing to do go get healthy
get on a sleep schedule where you're
doing like where you're getting some
good sleep eat good food stop eating
trash go outside move around this is
real right oh yeah I mean it's both and
I mean because without the structure
that we create the therapeutic process
that we try to do is not possible like
without the routine without the sleep
without the healthy eating can't
actually do that therapeutic part so
there's a lot that can happen in that
initial structure and physical activity
and all this and for those folks with
those clinical aspects that require a
deeper level of like therapeutic
intervention or psychiatric support
that's the framework that has to
maintain that never changes that
structure and stability is the main
component that sort of holds the
foundation for everything else to be
able to be possible so it's definitely
um you know with any sort of complex
human issue you can't say that one thing
is going to solve anything of course but
that is um undoubtedly the foundation
for 4 which all else sort of occurs for
for our folks and becomes the thing that
they maintain long term when they move
into their own houses they're still
getting up at a certain time they might
pick their day that they go grocery
shopping they might because that
structure and routine is is very helpful
human beings like that though and when
you live without it it's just the
beginning of
possible serious issues now here's uh
another thing that I talked about on a
podcast this was around
um mass shootings and and as as myself
and my friend Daryl were looking into
the various causes Behind These
masterings
one of the most shocking uh
pieces of information that we came
across is this right here so in 1955
in America there were 340 inpatient beds
per 100 000 people
so I'm gonna say that again in 1955
1955 for every hundred thousand people
there were in America there were 340
inpatient beds for mental health care
now here we are you fast forward to 2007
in 2007.
there were only 17 beds
for every hundred thousand people and
here we are we talk about mental health
all the time
now some of the feedback that I got
about that episode was that
in the 50s and 60s there were these
really heinous some really heinous
um events that happened inside these
psychiatric Wards and people were abused
and they pretty much from everything I
can tell threw the baby out of the
bathwater and just said oh you know what
we're just gonna shut these things abuse
happens in these places we'll shut them
all down
um
I I think about like you know I live in
San Diego I think about well there's a
couple million people in San Diego that
means that there would be a few thousand
inpatient beds if we were on the 1955
levels and if you go around San Diego
and you go look at the homeless people
many of whom have
psychological and mental health issues
if you opened up all those beds they
would probably fill them and we'd be in
a much different place and these people
would be getting some kind of treatment
that they actually need what what do you
think happened with this is it just the
the abuses that took place we shut them
down what is there anything else I mean
there's a there's a lot to this I mean
you're talking about the
institutionalization like I mean some of
this started even back into the 1700s
but there there's like at the time in
the time that you're referring to
primarily residential facilities is
where folks would be able to take their
loved ones with mental health right so
people have mental health issues they
went into these residential facilities
and that's where they primarily receive
treatment or just a place to say and
then as that evolved you know sometimes
I think the term Asylum came along at
some point this became a place where
people could stay and also work and
session they were having you know but
what was really happening on the inside
um was a pretty restrictive setting in
some ways and then there was some you
know people that had gone in and saw you
know all horrific stuff that was
happening and so ultimately all of these
sort of things move towards this idea
that a person is entitled to like the
least restrictive settings and there's a
lot of stuff that happened over the
course of the period of time for this
but that a person should not be chained
up they should be entitled to the least
restrictive setting and so
um then you also had the the notion then
coming in of SSDI and SSI and these
different things that started reform as
Federal movements but people what's SSDI
so it's Social Security disability
income or social security income that
came from like a federal movement so
this part where people who are in
inpatient facilities at the time were
not entitled to those resources and so
sort of force this Max set of Exodus as
discharge from hospitals for them to be
able to receive these services and what
you find at that time then it also some
of the States created sales that made it
much more difficult for people to
readmit to inpatient settings right so
the the notion was good this idea that
people will do better in the community
they'll do better in a least restrictive
setting let's create these resources
like SSD Ai and such like that for them
however it sort of flipped its on its
head in terms of the amount of resources
that the community wasn't ready to
absorb that so what we saw is sometimes
in some states I think California I
can't remember the year but in the year
of sort of discharge of hospitals out
into we saw the jail population double
in California
and the homeless population they think
what I recently read is something around
like 65 percent of the jails are are
full of people with mental health issues
I was talking to a police officer a
month month and a half ago and he he was
just he had heard that podcast and he's
like yeah he goes I 100 percent have to
arrest people and there's no possible
way that they belong in jail they belong
in some kind of a male to health
facility and there's nowhere to take
them so guess where they go they go to
jail right right or or they don't go
anywhere you know or they just get you
know they might get going to jail for
two nights and then they get kicked out
back out on the street and they're just
deteriorating well if you read about
this I mean depending on where you come
from Congressman rulemaker they're gonna
say Financial stuff whatever like
everybody has sort of a different
rationale as to you know why
de-institutionalization the outcome But
ultimately what we know is that we
didn't know anything really around that
time around complex psychiatric
illnesses it was just in the the major
50s at the first like the 1950s
antipsychotic drug was released prior to
that it was you know people with mental
illness like they never be cured right
there was the myth of mental illness we
didn't know too much about it and so I
think Thorazine was the first
antipsychotic that came out in the 1950s
and so at that point it was like oh well
people can get better and that was a
very also pivotal movement in the
deinstitutionalization of people that
historically had been able to be seen as
like they just will always need to live
in some type of facility it became oh we
can like do something with this and
today obviously there's there's tons of
different things but um
yeah it definitely had an impact on our
homosexual population is there any
movement back in the other direction at
all
I mean I don't know too much to speak to
that part but what I will say about like
Anew and what humble Chia had been for a
very long time is it's a very unique
model of care that allows for a full
Continuum of Care where people can have
um like a residential setting sort of
right out of the hospital for a
long-term period of time and then fluid
they move through transitional
residential for a person to be able to
kind of integrate what they need and
then also to be able to move back into
that inpatient setting if they need to
and instead of sort of this pattern of
I end up in the hospital I get
discharged to either home environment or
a place that's just not conducive for me
to be able to integrate that treatment
episode I'm out in the streets or I'm
not receiving the care I need until I
regress again that I've been up back in
the hospital and utilize all these
Emergency Services like and our our
model of care really allows people to
stay long term in a way that they can
move fluidly through this and avoid
really moving into the hospitalizations
but it's also um it's a it's a private
pay model it's a you know insurance is
not going to pay for that for folks
right because and so folks who are
primarily dependent on insurance and
such like that will find themselves in
more short-term environments
um kind of like like Crisis Intervention
environments which just it creates kind
of a revolving door right Christ I'm in
crisis I come in here for a couple of
days a couple of hours maybe a week
State stabilize get out there's nothing
available for me once I'm out so I
deteriorate and then I come back right
there or end up in jail because
oftentimes with mental illness sources
like the idea with
de-institutionalization was this idea of
people having more rights more agency
being out in the community not being
locked up but but then so be kind of the
least to to nothing that could hold them
so like what you were saying Megan is a
lot of our clients come in
from a hospital or like
could have been in one maybe they've
been maintained at home but like not not
well and it takes it's like this whole
Arc it takes a long time to stabilize
all the stuff we just talked about with
sleep and food before we can even get
into the nitty-gritty of like what is
going on here what needs to happen let's
get you off these 14 meds let's figure
out what has really happened like this
takes a long time so the idea was nice
it was like kind of a Humane idea but
the the outside world was not equipped
to receive all of these folks and and
actually help them so they got worse
deteriorated in their symptoms and then
they're getting arrested they're getting
picked up you know you go to a drop them
off at some emergency room they'll sit
in the lobby for a day or two get get
some meds there's your meds again and
they're out so so I I would think that
the long-term hope is that this model of
treatment which right now is basically
for people that can afford it and it's
expensive
is that over time people start to
recognize this should be a number one a
type of treatment that should be covered
by insurance and number two at some
point it gets to a a situation where the
public there can be some public offering
of treatment centers like this
but it's got to be proven for an even I
mean you've already been doing this for
how long Carlin 25 25 years you've seen
incredible successes over those 25 years
and
yeah I mean I I hope that as people hear
this as people learn more about the
methodology that you're using first of
all like just other people in the
private sector will pick up this type of
model and start moving with it and then
eventually Insurance hopefully starts to
cover it and then eventually we start
saying oh these you know these these
homeless people on the street that have
psychological problems
the worst thing we could do is take them
throw them into prison for or throw him
into jail for two days and kick him back
on the street we're just gonna do this
it's a never-ending cycle to get back to
a point where look do we want to have
people chained up to walls and having
lobotomies and having electroshock
therapy no obviously we don't that's
that's horrible and I I owe an episode
on some of those um some of those horror
shows that have taken place in the past
but to get to a point where there's only
17 beds per 100 000 people I mean you
take a hundred thousand human beings
with all the fragility of someone's
brain and mind and you think you're only
going to need 17 inpatient beds that's a
crazy thought and yet that's where we're
at so what my hope is is this model that
you all are executing starts to be seen
as the way to actually help people and
it can broaden Beyond
you know people that can afford this
type of treatment because this type of
treatment is very expensive
and and we can number one get insurance
to cover it and number two hopefully
eventually get it to a point where a
model like this can be used on a broader
public scale
um that that the state can pay for if
people need it and yeah like affordable
and accessible and by the way I just
want to uh pause because you have been a
great support to us I mean not only in
the a new treatment center but in our
previous facilities so like you said in
the beginning coming in is like I'm just
I'm going to invest some money here's
some guys you know but you know what
your contribution and your involvement
in that and staying involved I think
what seven eight nine years with our
group has helped make this this possible
um so thank you yes absolutely and um
but that would be my hope too right is
um what are this you know if you look at
any National Institute for mental health
or CDC one in five people has is
considered having like kind of a a
mental health
Experience One in 20
is considered as having like a serious
mental health
diagnosis or condition one in 20 so I
don't know the mass and 100 000 people
how many does that turn out to and we
got 17 beds right I mean it's it's
insane
it's horrible
um
probably a good place to wrap it up um
what what did we miss anything
yeah the one thing I was thinking about
earlier and you had mentioned
scaffolding and again I think this go
like goes with a lot of your work is my
understanding Jocko is this idea of
there is a need for external scaffolding
like you said earlier people like do
they like they don't really want to be
there nope they don't and in the
beginning that's totally fine we're
gonna like scaffold them up because
internally they're kind of jiggly and
not really set right
so we're going to hold them until things
can kind of firm up a little bit and
over time as they're building
we pull the external scaffolding back
because what is happening theoretically
is internally their their internal
scaffolding is is taking shape and
taking hold so it's very much about
helping people access their own agency
their own strength normalizing and
saying yep I get it today you know what
today is just a rough one that's fine
nothing is wrong with you yeah we're
just having one of those days and help
them develop that internal confidence
and agency of like self-management even
when you have an illness even if you
have PTSD even if you lost your friend
yeah well this is the uh
the title of the book that I wrote
discipline equals Freedom it's the exact
same thing right I mean it's like you
put the disciplines in in your life
around
um waking up around sticking to a
structure around going to get groceries
around
showering which you mentioned and you
mentioned it like very quickly you said
I don't know if you're showering look
you get people that are showering
absolutely that's an issue right so we
got to have the discipline to get up to
stay on a schedule to eat good foods to
shower to brush our teeth and once we
get that kind of scaffolding that kind
of discipline in place
then it becomes internal it becomes
self-discipline and now we can get more
and more freedom as time goes on 100
what are some good tactics techniques
and procedures for getting
someone to want to help themselves so I
you know I got a family member they you
know they're not dealing with reality or
they're they're they're they're starting
to show some of these signs what's
what's a step to take
that might be helpful so like a I have a
book called Extreme ownership and people
would say like well how do I get my boss
to read it and the worst thing you can
do is go to the boss and say hey boss
you need to read this book you know so
we say oh you go and say hey boss I read
this book it really helped me out a lot
I've been trying to hold myself to these
standards can you just look at it and if
you see me slipping can you type me up
you know a little indirect approach do
you have any recommendations around what
to do and maybe some recommendations of
what not to do sure yeah I mean I think
if your example consistency is huge and
patience too because oftentimes like we
want people to move at the level of our
ability to tolerate what's going on for
them and it's very uncomfortable to see
someone struggling it's very
uncomfortable to see someone so hopeless
you're hearing their narratives you're
like where are you even thinking at and
often we want them to move faster than
they're ready to move but what you're
describing with the framing around the
book is we plant seeds we create as much
structure and consistency as we can we
plant seeds we help people to kind of be
thinking about and you know how this
will impact them but every day it's the
sort of same conversation until they get
it and sort of a loving approach with
them until they get it and being able to
tolerate what comes up for me when
somebody isn't moving at the pace that I
want them to because when we're talking
about you know somebody who makes me
needs a little pick-me-up that
turnaround might be a lot quicker than
somebody with a chronic sort of complex
disorder and in that case like it might
take days or months before that person
gets up and goes showers on their own so
can I deal with my own frustration right
can I deal with my own sense of like
helplessness and like sense of
powerlessness or even inadequacy and not
being able to like shift like all these
things come up for someone when you're
loving somebody through something like
this but consistency is huge and then
remembering that you're not hurting
someone by trying to hold them in their
own discomfort right so if somebody is
uncomfortable but you're helping move
them through something that's good for
them you're not hurting them actually
they're experiencing that discomfort is
going to be really helpful for them it's
very loving thing to do there's a
conversation I have with parents often
about this notion of like hurting and
some ways when my child is experiencing
discomfort No in fact like experiencing
discomfort in this thing is actually
really motivating yes and amazing for
them and it's a super loving thing to do
um
yeah and I think it's important to
you know when I talked about oh it's
it's normal to go in like hey you're sad
that's normal hey you feel down when you
hear this song that's normal hey it's
also normal if you've got a kid or a
relative that's having some issues
that you take them to the engine shop to
get checked out and see what's going on
like this is also a normal thing so I
think that's another uh stigma to to to
punch through anything we should not do
any any warnings like hey that that's
not a good approach when you're trying
to get someone to help themselves
well I think like some of the examples
you used earlier like and even like when
the kids call and ask you questions is
like the not the shaming stuff like you
said like well what a mom who is going
to say something like like well why are
you doing that you're like those kind of
things aren't typically helpful because
nobody wants to be ill nobody wants to
have PTSD nobody wants to have these
symptoms so even on the surface if it
looks like why on Earth would you do
that
they're not doing it to like be
difficult or willful or to make
themselves you know worse so it's easy
it's part of the stigma to move into
kind of a shaming
um why why did you do that like that's
that's ridiculous or you you know better
than that like this kind of thing that
they I mean people will sink right they
kind of cower and sink into that and in
some ways might even come to believe
that I'm weak I'm uncapable I'm stupid
I'm whatever which is going to suck the
sense of agency right so encouragement
still tough La I mean it's a blend of
all these things like I'm going to be
kind and respectful also a little bit
firm also let you know that I absolutely
believe in you and so we're going to get
up right now and we're going to do this
thing even though I know you feel really
sad yep well and I would say to not
disregard your own intuition especially
when we're talking about suicide because
there's such a
there there's also could be a self
stigma in some ways and so if your
intuition has you wondering about
something or something seemed off with
them or oftentimes we can talk ourselves
out of that oh we don't step into other
people's business that somebody else's
kid or it's not my place to do that or
you know maybe if I bring this up it'll
make it worse for them you know and so I
think trusting our intuition is huge if
there's a pull in some ways to check in
with somebody or ask them how they're
doing or you notice something that feels
off
um I can't tell you how many times
especially when we're working in a peer
supported environment because we're
trying to get folks when we're bringing
them into this like housing and they're
living together to sort of notice each
other and take care of each other create
their own community and friendships when
we see something go kind of sideways
with someone or they regress
significantly or something happens and
you start asking their peers sort of
what was going on oftentimes they
noticed something but their intuition
talked them out of it they'll be mad at
me if I hold them accountable you know I
didn't tell everybody when I didn't see
that they were up for meds because I
didn't want to like kind of call them
out or whatever it might be and so I
think that you know know trusting our
intuition with that and like really
checking in with people and asking
important questions and working through
our own fears that we have related to
addressing some of these things are is
super important and your example of like
like hey that's like the fourth time you
went to the bathroom the last half an
hour right imagine like you were saying
if you hadn't said that
like what what that person would have
done in their head and how that would
have so I think one of the advice like
it's both is say something say something
call it out ask a question hey like
again the person might say oh I'm good
I'm good don't worry about it okay but
at least you saw them and they
versus like that Blind Eye I mean I
think the turning the Blind Eye not
saying the thing keeping the secrets
under the rug is the worst uh from a
leadership perspective I always often
talk about asking Earnest questions and
how that's a great indirect way to let
people know that you are watching and
that you're interested and it and the
key word is earnest it's not like hey I
noticed you know you you've been sad
lately
um what's what's wrong with you which is
an accusatory question as opposed to
being like you know hey hey uh what are
you doing this weekend like an Earnest
question that's an Earnest question what
are you doing this weekend oh I'm not
doing anything oh well what about next
weekend I'm not doing anything do you
want to do something like do you want to
go catch a movie you know so like these
kind of earnest questions are a good way
to interact with people without being
accusatory and and they might be like
yeah you know I no I haven't been doing
much lately because I've you know I've
been sick for the last few weeks and I'm
just gonna heal up and you go okay cool
yeah in which case cool great you can
carry on they know they saw you notice
that right yeah we talk about it as
being curious as opposed to a cute story
approaching everything with a certain
level of curiosity it'll take you a long
way that will do it
um Megan any closing thoughts
thank you yeah having us be here
extremely grateful to be a part of this
and yes I mean I think in terms of the
work that we do it takes a special type
of person to be to be able to have this
conversation to talk about this to to
work with this population to be a part
of it and and you're definitely a part
of that so thank you
you're calling anything else same thank
you for your support
um if anybody wants to find you the the
latest and greatest the new treatment
center is called Anew it's a good play
on words you did there yeah
um you're on Instagram so you're on
social media yeah with some positivity
yes and that's at a new treatment center
you're on Facebook you're on LinkedIn
and you're on YouTube you got your own
little YouTube channel going on
up and running a couple of the social
media part but I'm really glad that's
happening I and all those are at a new
treatment center and I was uh I was
thinking you two should do a little
podcast by the way I'm just gonna let
you know that you should do it you
should talk about like some cases that
you see because people will be
interested in it I think it would be
very educational and um I know I always
laugh because Joe Rogan told me to start
a podcast and at the time I was like oh
you know that's pretty cool and then you
realize Joe Rogan literally at one point
in time Joe Rogan told everyone on this
podcast and started podcast because he
was super stoked on podcasts well he
knew he was going to get it right in one
way or yeah I did a bunch of people a
bunch of people have started podcasts
but certainly him and Tim Ferriss both
told me to start a podcast and I
listened to him but um I think that if
you broke it down and did some podcasts
about some of the things that you see I
think it would really be helpful for
people and uh would be cool
um so there you go that's my little my
little recommendation and thanks for
joining us um thanks for educating us
thanks for trying to educate me I know
it can be challenging sometimes uh Megan
of course thanks for your service in the
Navy and uh thanks to both of you for
what you're doing today to help heal
people help get people to a point where
they can live productive and happy lives
and and by the way if there's anyone out
there right now that's listening
um
you might not feel great today
and you might need to uh bring the car
into the shop and get that thing looked
at and figure out what's going on
nothing wrong with it it's going to make
you better
thanks for doing that both of you thank
you appreciate it
and with that Megan and Carlin have left
the building and Echo Charles has
returned good evening Echo good evening
so you were sitting there listening yes
you've been taking the uh what the kind
of off camera
approach last two podcasts we've been
sitting there observing detached yeah a
lot going on there isn't there yes a lot
going on in the in the mental health
world yeah
yeah it's really it's like a slippery
scenario right because just like how you
get it's a spectrum it's not like oh
you're you know like you
compared to your body so if you break
your arm yep it's like oh yeah broken
arm yeah or maybe you got a fractured
arm
and that's sort of it's kind of a
distinct thing well fractured protocol
broken stress fracture okay a spiral
fracture okay you know kind of a thing
pretty limited like as far as a bone
break yeah you're kind of
there's a pretty specific protocol
you're going to follow it's pretty easy
to diagnose right the Spectrum isn't
this weird it's the it you know there's
guards are gray you know this bone
compound fracture or whatever like
there's some differences but we know
that a broken bone is a broken bone
here's how we fix it yeah and then
that's not okay then compared to the
mental part where it's like it's just
it's it's this spectrum and you can fall
anywhere on the Spectrum and by the way
you do fall on Like We All Fall that's
what makes it even that's what makes it
interesting that's what really that's
part of what makes it interesting to me
is like oh you're a little bit of a
narcissist I'm a little bit of a
narcissist I'm a little bit paranoid
you're a little bit how paranoid are you
are you good paranoid because there's a
certain level of paranoia like someone
that's not paranoid at all is just like
going through life they can just gonna
get taken advantage of you got to be
somewhat paranoid yeah delusional just
like the dichotomy of leadership like
the dichotomy of your mental uh status
is has to be balanced yeah that's and
that's so it makes it so clear how
helpful it is to understand and
inversely kind of to express that to
people who might be in a certain
situation that like hey that's that's
normal like there's nothing quote
unquote wrong that's normal you know and
um
so and that's what makes it even harder
too where it's like this bad thing this
thing that I don't want you know like
you break your arm something that you
hurt your arm will say you hurt before
you go to the doctor or whatever you
know something's wrong like this thing
is hurting it's not getting better
whatever let me go I know something's
wrong so mentally you're gonna feel sad
for two days or whatever you feel you
have these feelings for two days that
are normal
so it's like harder to you know
afterwards like maybe if I'm behaving in
a certain way it's like certain symptoms
have to kind of arrive or arise along
with the feeling yeah and it's all like
and if you don't know you don't know you
know so it's like just so slippery like
that I take down a note during that
catch 22 which which which basically
means because even with with uh Marcus
and Amber on the last podcast I was kind
of like you know I feel fine and like I
don't think I need anything right so I'm
telling them and then these guys show up
today
these girls show up today these women
show up today and I kind of tell them
same thing you know before we get in
here I'm like you know I I feel like you
know I'm fine but then
one of the no one of the like
notifications of when you're crazy is
when you don't think you're crazy right
so I'm like oh I'm that guy that doesn't
think he's crazy but I'm actually
totally crazy
so uh I thought that was kind of funny
as I was thinking through that I was
like wait a second I'm the guy that's
sitting here I'm fine yeah but I'm
actually crazy yeah oh yeah so gotta
watch out for that one yes and we all
know people maybe not a lot but we know
people who are like
they obviously routinely do things that
are just you shouldn't be doing that and
they're like no no I'm fine I'm fine
absolutely fine so you're like man am I
that guy just not knowing all the things
that I'm doing that's not fine you know
so gotta watch out for it but um what
what a
what a fascinating world and as I was
doing research for that podcast we only
got to so much I mean there's so every
one of these things when you open it up
I mean
there's a story in like a a whole world
behind
being paranoid and what a really
paranoid or being anorexic what a real
what that looks like like there's a
whole world behind each one of these
that's what's that's what's interesting
interesting like compared to
uh you know an orthopedic surgeon like
sure there's a bunch of different things
that can go on with a broken arm or with
whatever right but
you know this is just wildness yeah you
know it's wildness and you remember how
you a long time ago on the podcast you
said working out is like the one thing
that you can do that will positively
impact everything that you do in your
life well that proved to be right but
what's interesting is
having a broken arm
is going to impact some parts of your
life but it's not going to impact like
everything but if you have some kind of
a mental health issue
it's like everything is going to be
impacted and and again it's a spectrum
where it's like oh you know what now I'm
kind of like
I don't go out as much all right cool no
it's no big deal right
but then where does it go like does it I
don't go out much to hey I'm not gonna
go I'm I'm not gonna go to the grocery
store to I'm gonna have people drop my
food at the end of the hallway too I'm
just gonna sit in here and like not eat
like it gets it's just so it's very
strange and the other thing that I find
interesting is just how when I when I
talk when I talked to him about how I
had said in the academy like we're all
insane everyone's insane because your
version of reality is different than my
version reality and by the way neither
your version or my version is actually
correct like what your perception is is
not 100 correct my perception is not 100
correct we hope that you and I have a
big overlap like we hope that we have a
big huge overlap and there's like a
little bit that I think is a little
different a little bit but that's we
hope and we hope that with most people
in our lives most of it is relatively
close yeah but the fact is and also the
fact is they're not gonna be perfect and
different people like you can go me meet
someone today you and I have 97 overlap
we can go talk to someone right now that
we only overlap like 20 or 30 of reality
yeah their reality is just different
yeah
and that's a real thing that's a reality
so yeah
um
it's mayhem out there it is man out
there it's crazy man it it's crazy
because how they shed such a clear light
on like how it really works and it's
like man all this is going on right now
like in my head and this person in
everyone's head around us holy cow and
she'll mention like or
they'll mention like certain things
right where
you re it reminds you that hey I didn't
really think about this where like going
out going outside right I think actually
you said It Go um get outside
and not just outside the building I mean
I think anyway outside and talk to
people talk to different people be
around different people because you know
now a lot of my work quote-unquote work
is inside in front of the computer for
long periods of time so then I remember
not recently but this is like years ago
where I remember not going outside for a
few days like not going outside of the
building in a few days that's not
healthy yeah and you can feel it too
like after a while when you kind of in
touch with it like you can feel it or
not used not or being not used to being
around people when okay I used to work
in nightclub where year-round people all
the time all different Dynamic spectrum
of people all the time
positive negative everybody
um and then you know working inside
where you're not around a lot of people
like I can totally tell the difference
like the idea of me and this might have
to do with Age Two by the way but
the idea of going down and dealing with
the crowd of a nightclub or something
doesn't appear on any night is like that
is one of the last things I'd want to do
and then when I compare especially when
it compared to like how I was kind of
down with that long time ago you know
and so you take that idea and do it and
just apply it to everyday life I know
nightclub and all that stuff is
different a little bit different but in
everyday life if you're used to going
out to the store or going out to this
and that and then you don't go outside
for a long time or you just just simply
alone you just don't go outside for a
long time starting to go outside and
dealing with like people or the public
becomes more and more challenging just
because you're not used to it just like
any kind of exercise you do that's what
I'm saying and it
I can understand even more now how that
window shuts yeah and how that can jam
you up mentally yeah it doesn't seem
like you're made for that kind of stuff
you know it's been isolated and then
you're stuck with the internet all the
time oh man brother brother you gotta
watch you see that the internet
conversation could be a five hour
conversation oh yeah because it's it's
mayhem out there on the internet and if
you have that little belief I mean look
if you believe that uh uh
veganism is the best thing for you that
you can go insane if you believe that
the carnivore diet is about you can go
insane if you believe like whatever
weird belief that you want to have yeah
and you want to jump on the internet and
you want to read into that thing bruh
don't get off that internet man he's
gonna Jack you up oh yeah and the weird
thing is when I tell you if I'm like
Echo dude you got to get off the
internet you got to stop reading about
uh you know carnivore diet you'll be
like oh you just want me to keep eating
the mainstream diet you want me to it's
like that that's you see it's like it's
like a self-fulfilling prophecy oh yeah
so you got to get yourself out of the
algorithm let's watch out uh Hey that
being said one thing that we did talk
about today
was being healthy eating the right Foods
working out
this is coming from two people in the
industry for a quarter so well between
them it's probably I don't know 50 years
or something like they got a lot of
experience in this industry yeah and I
made kind of made fun of Rogan in me
saying like oh you should work out yeah
I kind of made fun of it and they're
like actually it's true yeah work out
eat right
stay on the path it's going to help you
in everything that you do so get
yourself some good
let's say supplementation yes to help
with that workout and that's the thing
actually probably in this boat too where
Segway just occurred you're welcome
everybody
that's the perfect chance but you'd
probably like to see where you pretty
much worked out your whole life probably
right yeah
I really didn't start legitimately
working out until I was like
first of all because working out wasn't
really a thing I mean it really wasn't
like there was no I'm one of my five
years older than you yeah so like yes
did we did we did we have uh Joe
weider's super weight gain back in like
1985 yes we did but we didn't understand
at least where I was I mean look maybe
if I'd have been
at uh some bigger school because I was
in like a little school like there was a
YMCA and there was a there was bumper
plates in there yeah like I had no idea
what I remember there was a blind guy
that would Olympic lift all day and I
actually thought at the time it was
because
like that was what he was limited to oh
yeah I thought well you know he can't
really see so he just stays in this one
spot and just lifts that one bar he
doesn't know how to use the freaking pec
deck
you know what I'm saying so yes I guess
I have been working out for a while yeah
so we and
so you weren't like a jock a Jocko but I
definitely was not like a jock although
I played
um soccer and basketball every year yep
oh okay so yeah yeah so you to me that
is working out so especially if you took
it even this much seriously so consider
and I'll use myself as an example so
when I was 11 years old I started actual
Sports
so you play football but you got no
push-ups right I remember you push-ups
and so I always thought that having big
muscles was cool yes so so I would do
that kind of stuff yes for sure and then
when you reach puberty
1340 probably like 15 years old we
started lifting weights so man from
there right it was on it was all one big
program yeah indefinite until now until
literally right now today until this
morning yes sir yes so it and this is
how it works essentially if you care
about sports care about your
performances Sports which we did so you
go on season obviously you're practicing
every day football and track that's what
we did so football's one season that
once football's over over get ready for
track between that side you're lifting
weight
so yeah you're just going from one sport
to lifting and conditioning to the next
word lifting and condition and back and
forth years through college
um
and then after college it was just
lifting and then when I got into Jiu
Jitsu okay now it's lifting and
conditioning for jiu jitsu tournaments
all this stuff so essentially being on
the program on the path on the from a
physical standpoint is has been decades
yeah but at as a result it's it is
served as like an anchor yeah so
you know the idea of like not working
out it's not a thing like oh he just
quit working out like bro I man it's
hard to relate even though it's so
common
so yeah I think if you can anchor that
the workout like my physical health is
like an anchor a given and it should be
because if your physical health falls
apart like it's gonna negatively impact
everything else now look you can get
sick and you guess what when you do get
sick if you get sick it is still going
to negatively impact everything else but
their sicknesses you don't have an
option on right like you get hit with
some horrible cancer out of nowhere like
what are you gonna do about that well
you you know you go through the protocol
you try and stay positive
but a lot of people does they don't get
hit with something they can't control
they hit with the one thing they can
control yeah and they let it slide which
is freaking horrible to see yeah uh so
let's not let it slide yep get on there
um and yeah take your supplements that
helps it that helps the physical part so
I'm saying Jocko has these good stuff
functional this is the line of
supplements I wish I always had yeah
that could have been a game changer
actually if if we were to have these
supplements our whole lives yeah be a
little different story
let's face it we navigate our supplement
um experience very ignorantly you know
the best advertisement wins straight up
like hey you see a buff guy on there
saying freaking 100 grams of protein
that's freaking Juiced to the absolute
gills yes oh yeah and you know so that's
that's what we're gonna get and he's
like yeah I take freaking whatever and
they come up with these crazy names Mega
Mass I forget the number I think it was
5 000.
very good brother tasted kind of good it
was in a big dog for weight game Mega
Mass 5000 like just get some oh yeah and
that's but so yeah now we know Brad's
not like that you got to take the
correct stuff made with the correct
stuff for the correct stuff so yeah
we're doing that we got joint stuff uh
Mulk which is the Protein that's the
protein we should have had back in the
day oh good not this Mega sugar 1
million or whatever it was before
um the energy drinks Jocko go yep the
first hell maybe not the first I don't
know I have no idea first fully healthy
energy drink yes yeah like and you drink
one you're healthier you're healthier
yes you just got better you just got
this you know like oh we've had good
health came in a can everyone else there
you go it does well one third of it see
I'm saying nutrition exercise rest
that's the trio
uh jockoffuel.com you can get all this
good stuff for you can support the
podcast you can support yourself you can
be healthy you can help your you can
help your mental health right we did a
freaking three hours on mental health
help your mental health by helping your
physical health you can get the drinks
at Wawa we got ah October 3rd I think
the Mulk RTD hits Wawa get in there get
yourself some banana get yourself some
chocolate get yourself some some vanilla
the best you can get it's the best the
best the highest quality look we are not
cutting corners
and believe me people want want you to
cut Corners yeah they want to make an
extra seven cents nope we could get an
extra seven cents out of every sale per
unit yeah if you put if you don't use a
natural sweetener if you use something
that's bad for you cool I made more
money off your health no we're not doing
that we are keeping healthy Joco
fuel.com Wawa vitamin shop uh HEB down
in Texas a bunch of different places if
they don't have it where you shop ask
them for it we'll get it to you
um
originusa.com we're doing Jiu Jitsu yeah
which means you need a ghee
you might as well get the best possible
gee in the world go to originusa.com get
yourself uh the best made ghee and it's
made in America just like the jeans just
like the just like the boots
awesome stuff the hunt gear
originusa.com don't forget that we don't
we have a store we do have a store and
what's that called it's called Jocko
store again the discipline equals
Freedom standard issue t-shirt is out we
made the announcement made it yesterday
to the people and you know good response
it's a good it's a good standard I'm
sure you put a YouTube video up of the
shirt Locker yeah it's kind of updated
yeah yeah oh is it an updated one a
little bit yeah
it's pretty cool quite frankly yeah it's
it's a metaphorical uh it's metaphorical
it's a metaphor for for what the shirt
Locker oh because my shirt's changing
yeah you know people I read the comments
I read some of the comments were like oh
how do you make a shirt change when you
didn't even take it off or whatever see
I'm saying so I'm saying hey it's a
metaphor it's a metaphor you wear a
shirt it changes every month
boom it doesn't really change on your
body the way it does in the video see
I'm saying you're wearing one of these
shirt Locker shirts right now is that
yes yeah it is the GI Joe one GI Joe rip
most recent one is called toxic
productivity it's a good one
it's a good one very good these
cartoonish pictures that you're
utilizing of me yep by the way yep
cartoonish pictures of me comic book
Comics pictures of me like
holding a weapon in each hand riding a
tank yep
uh that's funny stuff no yeah there's a
there's actually a lot of good designs
on there um you know I don't know if
they come up uh for sometimes people
request certain types of designs we go
down a rabbit hole looking into it you
know the viability of certain ones and
some of them is just real obvious that
just need to be made into shirts so
you know they're fun anyway that's
called the shirt Locker once your new
shirt every month
um cool thing people seem to like it
check that out it's all on Jocko's store
uh subscribe to the podcast don't forget
about Jocko underground.com
it's penciled yeah
people getting pulled off of platforms
we don't own this platform look are we
talking about some crazy controversial
thing not really do we talk about some
things that maybe could get us put in a
situation yes we do we have we've had
warnings on some of our YouTube videos
that they had to get fact checked oh
yeah
so that's an indicator that you know
maybe we're getting looked at well
obviously we are getting looked at so to
combat that to make sure that we always
have the ability to get information here
we have Jocko underground Jocko
underground.com
we do an extra little podcast we put on
there answer your questions uh doc
underground.com if you want to support
their go support we appreciate it if you
can't afford it it's eight dollars and
18 cents a month
what do they say like let's do a cup of
coffee was that what they say yeah
sometimes one it is like about things
yeah well if you have a cup of coffee
every day yeah and you're buying it from
one of the
like more well-known coffee shops you're
definitely spending more than eight
dollars and 18 cents oh yeah monthly
even if you're having the most unless
you're not drinking coffee at all you're
spending more than 18. even if you're
going to the grocery store getting
yeah you're gonna spend maybe eight
bucks maybe so coffee pretty cheap you
get if you can't afford it we still want
you in the game we still want to be able
to talk to you in case things go
sideways assistants email assistance.com
we have a YouTube channel check that out
we have psychological warfare
people have that on their playlist on
iTunes yeah it's an MP3 that you can
just if you're going through life you
might experience a little moment of
weakness this will help get you through
it flipsidecanvas.com Dakota Meyer's
company get cool stuff to hang on your
wall
which is nice keep you on the path I've
written a bunch of books you can check
out those books at some point if you're
interested about the things we do here
uh Echelon front leadership consultancy
go to aslamfront.com if you need help in
your organization
we can help you we can help you through
leadership we solve problems through
leadership go to ashlandfront.com for
details on that we also have an online
training academy I mentioned that a
couple times today
where we teach leadership now look
leadership it doesn't mean that you're
the CEO or you're the CEO are you the
commanding officer there's leadership no
matter where you are in an organization
even if you're the front line
individual contributor or the front line
assaulter on a team
you are still in a leadership position
you're leading your teammates you're
actually leading your boss you're
leading your family you're leading your
friends
become a better leader and you'll have a
better life go to extreme ownership.com
join the academy
and if you want to help service members
active and retired you want to help
their families gold star families check
out Markley's mom mama Lee she's got a
charity organization if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
America's Mighty Warriors dot org don't
forget about also Micah Fink's
organization
Heroes and horses.org also check out
Marcus and Amber
Capone they've got
vetsolutions.org check out some of those
Charities and if you want to connect
once again if you want to connect with a
new treatment center
a-n-e-w Treatment Center
go to a new treatmentcenter.com they're
on social as well a new treatment center
on Facebook LinkedIn YouTube Instagram
they're there
and as for us we're also in those places
Echo is that Echo Charles I am at Jocko
willink of course be wary be wary of
that that algorithm and uh thanks once
again to Megan and Carlin for joining us
today to share their knowledge with us
to try and educate me and thanks to both
them for dedicating their lives to
helping other people
also thanks to all our service men and
women out there around the globe that
are standing watch against evil and a
big thanks to our police and law
enforcement paramedics EMTs dispatchers
firefighters correctional officers
border patrol Secret Service all the
First Responders thank you for
protecting us from evil here at home
and everyone else out there
pay attention
pay attention to that mental check
engine light do you pay attention to
your own
pay attention to people around you
and if that
check engine light comes on don't just
keep driving
pull over for a minute
call that mind mechanic call that
therapist or that psychologist
who can help get your mind back up and
running the way it's supposed to so that
you can
go out
and get after it
and until next time the zeko and Jocko
out